conceptually live
all right my friends reject Nation
citizens people of the community how are
you guys is this time you know the drill
let us know if we're live we cannot
proceed with bringing you
the this is whatever it's gonna be
whatever this is gonna be the Last Week
Tonight of comic book news it's gonna be
really interesting this flavor I'm
excited about doing this yeah you guys
don't see but we usually do about 20 to
30 minute lead-ins for DC animated
movies we have to cut and now we're live
they won't be cut oh It's gotta be chaos
and I'm ready for it you're very good at
generating deleted takes to use on
patreon I feel like that's both a good
and bad thing for everyone involved sure
yes I think that's probably a solid
assessment for guys we are live thank
you for being here we are going to talk
about uh some of the latest MCU and DCU
news and hey hey uh Panda thank you so
much for uh for already kicking off the
super chats and uh and what a panda yes
yes you are no longer endangered in our
hearts
um but yeah no seriously thank you for
uh kicking that off we're gonna get to
the super chats uh ASAP but uh you know
starting out with a couple of the
mainline news stories um but yeah just
thank you guys for chiming in and for
you know contributing to the chat and
everybody who contributed to the last
live stream as well propelled some
really fun and enjoyable conversation
and uh and yeah we're gonna try to get
to everybody in a timely manner today uh
and we are the best guys to keep
official we are very linear we're on a
path we're on a mission it won't Meander
and become all sorts of Wu-Tang
references not here this is not going to
be the Redux of our long-lost what would
dick listen to podcasts man I gotta tell
you I almost made a Spotify playlist I
like actually thought about it how would
that be to make like playlists for
different like actors as roles as well
as the characters roles and like that
way you shape The Narrative of what
flavor of that character it would be
that's oh hey okay look every member of
gorillas oh every animated member of
gorillas has like their own playlists
right on these various platforms so you
could do that like imagine the Teen
Titans playlist like separately and then
together like all the different stuff
that like I feel like the most eclectic
might be Beast Boy but I feel like them
most like my vibe would be Raven sure
ooh because I feel like Raven would be
like not just atmospheric gloomy like I
definitely think she'd like the Cure and
early Nine Inch Nails but I also feel
like she'd like mess with some 90s
hip-hop like I don't know why but I just
feel like she she'd had fun Jam this is
go okay so that's exactly what we're
doing you guys ruminate on that and uh
yeah comment any and all of your best
picks but I just shout a few of you out
first and foremost for being here what's
up to Beantown Brandon 80s kid from the
90s Evie blue
uh Bryce Burris Lloyd just Lloyd just
Lloyd Mega YouTube 99 thank you guys so
much for being here doe eyes philosophy
[Music]
Tracy official awesome he's a great name
yeah it is I want to give credit to
philosophy that's dope philosophy
awesome fee all right and our boy Bucky
Barnes holding down the chat moderation
very much appreciates you um let's get
it let's let's start with top stories
yeah let's start with the most positive
story of the week uh we gotta start
there we got a trailer for the Marvels
which uh unanimously everyone enjoyed
beloved it's the most successful trailer
they're thinking of not even releasing
the movie but just touring the trailer
and screening it in different cities
because of how much people are loving I
hear they're gonna play it 30 times and
that'll be future length yeah and
they're just gonna let that be the
experience people pay for they love it
it's gonna go so well yeah totally
that's that's that's the plan right now
and it seems like a solid business model
for them moving forward I feel like I
should pref before as we get into it as
we because it's part of the journey I uh
I put out uh a tweet and Instagram that
I stand by a lot of people say I put out
a tweet as if it's like
you know what
280 characters or so added a graphic and
sent it into the universe very big PR
move uh no but I I uh I put out a tweet
uh basically saying like in nine hours
all of the weakest willed men are going
to hide behind buzzwords as a way of
critiquing uh the Marvels and a lot of
people were triggered by that which I
found uh both expected and entertaining
in that um I didn't say the only reason
you wouldn't like it is if you were weak
build but I said that the weak world
would hide behind buzzwords so anyone
that felt that um that I was talking to
them that's that's on you uh not me and
then exactly that occurred I don't think
you're a misogynist if you don't enjoy
the Marvels but I do think misogynists
won't enjoy the Marvels like they're
mutually exclusive Concepts I didn't
think Captain misogynists are dedicated
to not exactly joining the Marvels
they've made up their minds and they do
it without actual critical analysis
that's the difference is like when I say
very specifically in the Tweet the
buzzwords element it's because they
don't actually have anything to say
they're just cowards so it's a really
interesting like duality of people being
like Oh no I've been hurt by this mean
man and the actual reality of there are
a lot of people that just don't like
strong women and those people aren't
worth existing like I just don't think
that should be the the thing we hide
behind tear down the chat right I mean
let's just get rid open to the top uh no
it'll bring in all the people that love
putting American flags and so like
those people will rally but I just think
it's really important to acknowledge
like I didn't think Captain Marvel was
that great it's in my bottom four MCU
but because of the people that don't
like it for no good reason it's harder
to talk about it's harder to criticize a
movie that I wanted to be good that I
thought should be good but the things I
don't like about it have nothing to do
with it has to do with the filmmaking
like I think that the first one was
directed in a very
um superficial way it had a lot of like
we get it she's Rising like she Rose
like 82 times and the the telegraphed
Twist and all the those things and the
reason I think the Marvels is going to
be so good is I think Nia Dacosta is an
incredible director I love Candyman I
think that Aman villani is charm
incarnate I think Brie Larson has found
a different route to Carol Danvers and I
think what uh Tiana Paris is going to do
with spectrum is going to be a great
balance between Carol and Aman villani's
take on Kamala Khan so all of the
ingredients are already a better uh soup
in my opinion they got a stew going and
I think that that plus the fact that
Marvel is looking to recalibrate
strongly this movie was shot before they
uh decided to like pause and adjust and
like really look at their stuff but they
are having more time to edit they are
having more time to play with tone they
are having more time for visual effects
so I think the Marvels has a lot of
potential to be the thing that I wanted
the first Captain Marvel to be and
that's why I'm so excited for this one
because I do like the character I do
like the cast I do like the director
yeah and I mean it makes a lot of sense
that even though yeah this is you know
coming on the heels of a time where
they're just starting to Pivot and
adjust some things I feel like Captain
Marvel would be the one that in every
phase of its production no matter what
the rest of the MCU is going through
they probably wanted to lead to just
give the opportunity to to start it out
on the best foot right to make it as
good as it could possibly be to bridge
some of that Gap from the first movie
because as much as there is that you
know as much as there is this kind of
backlash and relating it back to the
story at least as of uh
at least as of yesterday this is it's
got to be above 500 000 dislikes now
like there are different reported
numbers depending on what time of day
articles were published I have one here
saying there's 468
000 dislikes uh and suggesting that you
know the likes are certainly less than
that by about 24 25 000 at least it's
got to be higher now the ratio but yeah
I mean like I I wonder what it must be
like to be anybody involved with a film
like this because it does
there are lots of ways in which I think
you can yeah twist arguments
or or the nuances of arguments to be
like ah people are just dedicated to not
liking this but in in the case of
Captain Marvel there is I think just
very apparently a contingency of people
committed to not liking and like the
movie did make its billion with a B but
it's not one that's discussed now it's
not a movie that gets brought up in
topless it's not a movie like just
because a profit doesn't equal quality
and that's a very interesting line when
you're talking about a sequel when
you're talking about one with this high
of stakes I'd argue the Marvels is the
next phase five film because Guardians
is its own bubble it's safe Guardians is
the end of something not the beginning
of something and after quantumania it
feels like the stakes couldn't be higher
on the Marvels like this movie is in a
very unfair position of having so much
weight on it and I personally thought
the trailer
captured that fun cosmic energy uh
spontaneity buddy cop
um like body swap charm like it did all
the things it needed to do so there's
nothing in that trailer except for
people's stupidity that warrants 500 000
dislikes that's that's my point oh
that's that's what I was trying to
express and the amount of vitrol I got
on the internet wasn't surprising it's
just like unoriginal like everyone's
comments are as dumb as I expected
everyone's reasons yeah it's like copy
paste the the dumb ass ahead of you like
it's it's just so sad that we're like
it's 2023 and the idea that people don't
want to see certain people on screen
because they aren't them is tragic like
it's just like what what's the point of
making art if it's going to be the same
thing and that's that's just I don't
know one kind of good art course
obviously guys uh I'll put it to you
though I mean how did you guys feel
about the trailer did you leave a
dislike did you leave a like did you do
nothing at all they say people are more
likely to express themselves when
they're displeased with something I like
the trailer quite a bit I mean I was a
little
uh it was one of those things where I
wasn't like boom like damn I'm just
overwhelmed with how crazy hyped this
looks but I was I was like curiously
drawn in it was like kind of not exactly
what I expected in like a neat way so it
wasn't the Guardians trailer for me and
that I was like oh I'm not ready for how
good this looks but it also was a oh I'm
now more excited for this with more
context it gave me enough story it did
what a teaser what five months out six
months out like that movie's out not out
till November it's almost like it's over
half a year away like it's it's month
four and that's month ten it's half a
year away it did what it needed to do to
remind us to be excited um but yeah the
reaction's just been so unfortunately
expected sure and and speaking of uh oh
what's a good segue here speaking of
the unexpected but maybe not the
unexpected we also have some potential
uh director decisions
DCU moving forward for uh specifically
Brave in the Bold correct yes so this
rumor has gotten some more heat over the
last few days and this alongside the
next room we're gonna talk about and the
confirmation of Swamp Thing being
directed and written by the great James
Manuel this is confirmed James Mongol is
confirmed to be writing and directing
you heard it here
thing
mushy Eddie on Batman brave in the bowls
sick
Matthew Von and the authority is what
I'm hearing okay okay well yeah okay so
this this sounds uh that sounds like a
very uh likely but not in a not in the
way people mean that as like a slight
I'm like well yeah these choices they
make sense yeah and that's it's like a
passionate choice because to me
mangold's coming off Indiana Jones going
into Star Wars he could do anything he
wants in the world right now sure and he
referenced Bernie wrightson on a Star
Wars red carpet he literally name
dropped one of the great artists in
comic books on Swamp Thing at a Star
Wars red carpet and I got to be like
and then Matthew Vaughn ahead of my man
moment and then Matthew Vaughn who I
think is responsible for one of the most
underappreciated comic book movies of
all time X-Men first Class I'm not
saying it's one of the best though I am
I am saying it is one of the most
underappreciated uh I think he also has
a very Mark Miller responsibility
they've worked together Mark Miller and
him Mark Miller made the authority uh
second volume uh he also is a man of the
sassy British repute which is very The
Authority like that guy Richie Matthew
Vaughn energy is exactly what you're
going to want out of the authority and
then that energy is going to translate
into this great Darkness to be a
dichotomy to the Justice League and then
Batman I've been saying from the first
word of mouth about the flash being the
second coming uh that he should do
Superman
it makes sense that James Khan is going
to be like well I I wrote the thing and
I've decided I'm gonna do something so
what do you give the guy that's
literally making the movie that I hear
is Dark Knight good what do you give the
guy that's clearly in love with the DC
Universe that his franchise is as much
as they're talking about going on
probably just talking about going on I
can't imagine it actually gets a flash
too I could be wrong but if that guy's
not gonna get to make something in that
same exact wheelhouse who else is as big
as Superman but the Batman himself and I
think that the dark sensibilities of it
I think obviously mama like his
background I would love to see him
handle a Batman in that vein but also
the way the Flash trailer looked he was
directing in Tim Burton style he was
directing in a very Snyder style he's
able to capture those different energies
and make I mean we did the trailer
reaction the first thing I noticed was
how incredible it was that it looked
like different karmic artists jamming
because he'd grab directing Styles if he
can add his own Batman style to that
Pantheon and then also he's going good
at directing kids with it he's good at
doing all these things that are going to
be necessary for a paternal Batman story
I think this actually might be even
better than him directing Superman I can
see that for sure I mean like that's
that Prospect excites me because yeah I
feel like this could be an opportunity
to really see what his style is in this
Arena I mean the flash obviously is
going to do that but yeah it's like you
know you had stuff like Mama that is
more I I would think his direct voice
his direct tone that's his baby whereas
something like it you know you have and
I like chapter one a lot I I didn't like
chapter two quite as much but you know
that has its own Stephen King Nest to
embody and stuff like that and that is a
more Blockbuster horror flick than you
know a more you know individually
authored one not to not to remove you
know he clearly authored that piece but
but yeah you know moving from that then
to you know this Arena yeah the flash is
one where I'm like okay interesting but
the Batman I'm like or Brave and Bold
specifically I'm like oh cool because
yeah especially with what like you just
said yeah his ability to work with uh
the younger cast as well as the adult
cast and then you know bring those dark
sensibilities I think that'll be really
something special and something that
that like will give
I feel like that may create the
opportunity to see like what is yeti
yeah yeah that's what I see it's like
our greatest hits album like he's making
like all of the pieces of his repertoire
in a Batman movie also mangled Von
mushieri like what a launch if they
really are doing all of that as the jump
then I keep saying I I think Marvel is
going to get better because DC is going
to be incredible I think DC in the next
five ten years is going to be like the
PowerHouse it should have always been
and Marvel's gonna have to learn like to
to reposition because they're gonna have
to learn from each other oh it's like
the the Patriots like the one you know
you can't let the Patriots get
comfortable because like then every
other team is like we've seen they've
got another ring all of a sudden you
can't let them how many rings like Kevin
feige's Brady with all those gauntlets
like he's just like holding the gauntlet
of Super Bowl rings and now other teams
are catching up so I I think it's good
for all of us and I and I'm really
excited about those three names well I
put it to the chat guys which uh which
title and director are you most excited
for uh James mangle Swamp Thing Andy
mushieri's Batman brain in the Bold or
Matt Vaughn's The Authority uh I'm very
curious because especially I mean not
just not to spoil what's coming up in
our DC viewing but we've seen some
things lately uh that you know hearken
to what uh what I would imagine an
authority tone would be like yeah and
like that's one of those things where
I'm like Matthew Vaughn seems like he's
just this side of like yeah it seems
like the choice like sometimes you you
feel like a choice is like oh yeah
that's that's kind of on the nose right
but I feel like it's just it's not yeah
it's not so like well that makes sense
it's like oh that makes sense it's got a
little inflection in it I also think
that it's exciting that we've got
Matthew Vaughn mushitti and um mangled
as like those are some of the directors
oh okay sorry I didn't want to lose the
first rat top in the first Super Chat
sorry wait we get very distracted Greg
appeared peripherally literally was a
jump scare for me
but that's a good segue let's hop into
the first Super chat right now in fact
uh but yeah let us know which one you
are most excited for oh finishing that
thought so sorry yeah uh I love that
those three directors that 10 years ago
those names wouldn't have been as this
like moment so it feels like this next
wave of like holy crap this this team of
directors and also the name Swamp Thing
The Authority in Batman all being at the
same tier of excitement is already
inherently exciting yeah all right so
hopping in first Super Chat thank you so
much to uh everybody who has uh
contributed so far I see we have a few
to catch up on uh but the panda you have
started us off so you will go up first
uh hey John hey Panda thank you for
being here love your DC reactions
particularly Superman and Lois uh have
you and Greg talked about when you'll do
season three it's been an amazing season
and the Superman and Lois reactions are
my favorite uh yeah keeping this one
pretty quick because we did address this
uh last week uh big love for Superman
and Lois very excited to catch up with
season three haven't seen any of it as
of yet uh just the the like likelihood
of the reaction series returning as of
now is pretty low just uh to to be frank
there are many considerations and a lot
of hours that go into these videos and
with just the ever evolving shape of how
things work around here and what needs
to happen in order to keep everything
running uh it hasn't been uh it's just
there are a lot of obstacles to getting
that one uh you know fully
um
yeah uh it's just been a a kind of
difficult one to fit back into the
schedule so I'm not really sure what
form if at all it'll come back in but uh
but yeah as of right now uh no real
plans
um
but yeah uh so you know we'll see but uh
big big love for that show anyway and
I'm glad you guys are still enjoying it
and uh hopefully at some point we can uh
we can hop back into uh we can hop back
in but yeah I don't expect to see
reactions on the channel anytime soon
really
um so yeah uh but thank you very much
for uh Your Enthusiasm at the very least
uh Mota motasam uh keep doing what y'all
doing appreciate the love appreciate the
encouragement and uh yeah appreciate the
support thank you for showing your
support you are part of the glue that
holds this community together and we
very much appreciate you so thank you
for being here thank you for spending
your Saturday morning with us Bucky
Barnes holding it down moderating the
chat uh this is a great uh this is the
way happy Saturday gents cheers cheers
to you this is the way hope you're also
enjoying El mandaloriano
um but yeah if people seem to have all
kinds of feelings about that show right
now but I'm glad that you're bringing
that one with the penultimate episode
right there's one more true that yep one
more and again John for the finale John
Favreau guarantees it will be satisfying
oh guaranteed yeah absolutely that feels
like a confident statement oh here's a
koi one from
I like it a lot of owls myself very dope
name um so hey koi missed you in the
last live stream
koi made a point he was like I know that
I'm not going to be there my uncle's not
going to be there I'm going to tag out
what was it
yeah this weekend before last weekend
this weekend Greg and I did some movie
news I think I was in Florida I think
yeah you were you were doing yeah I was
with Charlie and Vincent that's why so
check out some McCoy's uh Recaps on his
Twitter and such hey I'm getting clips
for y'all but yeah I missed you last
week on the stream uh with the
unjustified backlash on the Marvel's
teaser what do you think would be the
way forward that's a good question why
don't you why don't you take it away uh
I think the solution is uh don't blindly
see movies for the sake of pivoting away
from the conversation but if you do
enjoy the movie be vocal about it
because the uh yeah I'm gonna use this
word and it's gonna be
take it out of context but anyone that
is a racist a bigot or a misogynist is
the enemy so I'm going to say the word
enemy if the enemy is going to be loud
and vitrollic because I think that
people that are hateful for the sake of
hateful are the enemy then you likewise
need to be that vocal right so I think
it's important the reason I've pivoted
how I handle my social media is one I
get a lot out of uh trolling trolls I
enjoy it and two because hate is the
most popular emotion on social media
hate gets more likes hate gets more
views hate gets um a lot of ground like
it moves the needle and I don't hate art
I I can't make movies I can't make uh a
painting I can't make music I am not the
person to hate on Art I think it's it's
not my place so you won't see me hating
on Art but what you will see me hating
on is hate and I enjoy that so very much
I enjoy that I have anger in me that I
can let out on people that are hating on
things and if they're hating on things
for the sake of just being a bad person
I'm gonna let them know they're a bad
person so the way I think we show our
support is if you do in fact like the
Marvels don't lie if you don't like it
don't don't say you like it but if you
do like it be vocal about it if you do
enjoy you know representation on a team
of any kind whether it's someone that
looks like you someone that doesn't
someone that's you know a strong woman
or someone that's like this this guy
you've always wanted to see on camera I
got excited when um druig was actually
Irish in in the eternals and like I got
to be excited to have that my like
people represented so being vocal about
what you want to see and voting with
your wallet and being uh outspoken about
stuff is the only way to counter
ignorance and to counter the people that
are being so loud so uh be articulate in
it be intelligent about it but do be
vocal I think is the way yeah yeah sure
that's fair yeah be genuine about it and
uh and yeah I don't know they're gonna
have to they're just gonna have to
proceed and be confident in themselves
and uh and yeah if you're a fan and you
see
BS out there call it out you know yeah
um but yeah very much appreciate uh the
question and uh and yeah I don't know
what do you guys think Marvel should do
moving ahead with the Marvels you know I
feel like it's it's a very unfortunate
position for all those people to be in
and I do not envy that that weirdness
that they must you know be feeling right
now a Christian unpronounceable
I hope I said that correctly
Coy's boys that's right
Saturday he's a new rock stars uh
frequenter and it is good to see you
over here on real rejects much
appreciated uh they call my fans over so
the koi pond is what my fans call each
other on my stuffs but the koi boys was
born a new rock stars so that is uh some
new rock stars love much appreciated
well before we hop into the next uh
Super Chat uh why don't we at least
discuss another a little piece of MCU
news uh hop back to the I mean you know
we've been talking about the Marvels
again but uh hop back into some new MCU
news there has been some Deadpool 3
casting information as well as some
potential plotting uh Miranda Baccarin
is going to return as Vanessa different
Vanessa but Vanessa that's a really good
I never realized that that Deadpool's
wifey and kingpin's wifey have the same
name that is a Martha moment waiting to
happen in Deadpool 3. I hope that
because now he's in the MCU you could
totally have a Vanessa sure oh if he
says I've embarrassed me in front of
Vanessa if Ryan Reynolds says you've
embarrassed me in front of Vanessa you
just blew my mind John I'm so excited
it's gonna happen don't even don't even
trip and we also have oh my God what is
the actor's name but the guy who plays
Colossus uh is also going to uh return
for Deadpool three that would be Stefan
capichik I hope I'm saying his name
right and uh you know really delightful
you know both uh humorous foil but also
you know formidable presence in uh
Deadpool and uh bring back Lewis tan
bring back Brad Pitt bring back like I
mean just do it and I'm really uh
curious to see what the plot ultimately
winds up being I mean I've heard you
know obviously we there's been the
accepted notion that the TVA is going to
be heavily involved or or Mobius in some
manner shape or form is going to be
involved some people think that that
will have to be do with you know saving
Wolverine from an untimely demise but
also it could have to do I've heard
speculation that having Vanessa back
could uh lead to some kind of you know
like he saved her from death and so them
being like well you know that has to
that's an event that has to be you know
and basically the TVA sort of trying to
impose that thing of you need to let go
of your love in order to uh you know set
the timeline straight again uh or
whatever that might be which sounds like
you know a kind of reasonable you know
plot line to to go about I love the idea
of doing a uh like Deadpool trying to
stop people from dying that he cares
about including her and Wolverine and
the TVA trying to like nip all those new
timelines and that allows for like X-Men
cameos that allows for all those things
but I I truly do still hope and think
it's going to be some sort of Deadpool
kills the fox Universe I think he's
going to be cleaning up continuity for
the TVA I think uh maybe you know in
order to save Vanessa he cleans up Fox
continuity which would be really fun to
like have him going through and like
taking out like last appearance chances
of fox characters because we've also
heard rumor that
um you know like McAvoy uh lyncher uh
what fast spinner there we go I was like
Eric lyncher is the character uh you
know those characters appearing would be
a really fun way to get rid of those old
continuity so I could see any number of
those things and the more casting
announcements we hear the more that
seems plausible and this movie sounds
enormous and glorious I can't wait yeah
yeah it's gonna be exciting I feel like
they're they are very much building up a
new event and I'm enjoying just the
anticipation of that but uh who are you
most excited to see and are there any
characters that you guys
hope show up that we have no inclination
as to whether they will or not or no
rumors or anything else there's a wish
list that you guys have for Deadpool 3
in terms of characters uh sound off I
just want a full like vanisher storyline
sure let's do that I would I would be
very excited to meet that Prospect it
would be fun if Sean Levy is able to get
Taryn Edgerton to Cameo as Wolverine as
like a John Krasinski follow the rules
like Daniel Radcliffe's in it like he
takes out other Wolverines yeah like
that's the plot point is John Levy's
like they kill him everyone loves that
Wolverine that'd be so great sure
somebody uh quote blink in the chat says
I need more of koi's comic Corner
Batman psychology video I kind of I kind
of love I'm excited for that to happen
sir uh my uncle let's let's hop into
another Super Chat real here really
quick and again thank you guys so much
for contributing and for you know you
guys we have a few top stories
um you know that Greg has assembled you
know and and that we want to talk about
and that we've battered back and forth
but you know you guys drive the chat and
the topics uh largely so thank you for
contributing and for your enthusiasm
myunk run on avare again I hope I'm
doing okay with your name hey koi and
John hello to you uh will Guardians of
the Galaxy 3 and the Marvels be
connected somehow and given that they
are both space movies could one of them
reference the other I think there's a
high probability one could reference the
other I kind of doubt that they will
have any like really significant
narrative connecting tissue just because
it does seem like Guardians the whole
point is that it's
gonna cap off this Saga it's gonna cap
off the involvement of so many of these
actors of James Gunn and I feel like
that's going to be a pretty contained
Affair that may have Ripples and effects
Beyond itself but I doubt uh I doubt
that you know like the Marvel's gonna
factor in very heavily to something like
Guardians 3 and I doubt that like the
direct plotting of Guardians 3 will be
broad enough that it will be you know
Earth shattering to the Marvels I yeah I
agree I feel like uh the Guardians is is
going to be as contained as a Marvel
movie can be this deep into phases I
think a post-credits scene at most but I
honestly hope it's it's Iron Man one
level contained like the end of Iron Man
like acknowledges The Avengers but like
I really I let the Guardians be their
own thing as they get their swan song
that makes sense yeah yeah I think
that's the most appropriate way to do it
look at a post credit I wouldn't want
like it's like wakanda forever if they
put Doom in there like the rumors were
that would have felt really like why and
I really hope that the Guardians get
that same reverence yeah yeah let's I
think certain movies should be their own
movies and I think they're at least
decent at figuring that out when it's
especially important I think and two I
mean Deadpool is going to be also its
own little trial balloon right see how
that all ties in that comedy and they
all ratedness like the the first r rated
movie is going to be exciting to see how
that does it with a Marvel Banner on it
yes there's there's a lot of different
things happening it's like the Marvels
has to establish its own footing again
post Captain Marvel so yeah I feel like
these movies
not to just lump Deadpool 3 and with
them but all three of these that we've
been talking about on the MCU side have
their own things to prove or to rap
certainly uh raccoon shampoo gotta try
some of that out I feel like a bandit uh
how do you feel about the whole
character X doesn't need a show or a
movie kind of thing uh it comes up with
Harkness and a lot of James Gunn's DC
projects I thought people would learn
their lesson after saying that about and
or I guess not
um yeah I mean I think I I fall on the
side of anything has potential given
enough time and thought to be good you
know like you get surprised by things
all the time so uh I think it's possible
that any character could lend itself
well to a movie but at the same time
yeah certain characters seem like
trickier prospects than others uh and uh
yeah I don't know it's like an Andor
might not be the most obvious thing but
they clearly wanted to tell a certain
kind of story with that and there are a
lot of characters not just Andor and I
think they found a good way to sort of
uh pluck him into and out of you know in
in different ways a bigger scope I this
might be a hot take but the more
obscured the character the more freedom
so therefore if you want to make a lot
of money make a Batman at 200 million
dollars if you want to make a lot of
heart and energy of your take on
something you make an individual
character popular I think that
um I think there's a reason Donald
Glover would rather play Hypno Hustler
uh I think that that you know a lot of
people are going to judge it but I think
he's going to have a lot of freedom in
that and I think that these characters
that James Gunn is making are going to
allow the DC Universe to be more
original I think the DC Universe is
going to pull in directors like Matthew
Vaughn and James Mangold and Andy
muschietti sticking around because
mushieri will get to make that tenpole
while Mangold gets to make something
that's going to be his vision of Swamp
Thing and Matthew Vaughn like he got
taken off of X-Men when Brian Singer
came back and I would argue that Brian
Singer made a lot of really good mutant
movies but never made an X-Men movie
Matthew Vaughn made an X-Men movie every
decision that they had with the problems
I have with X-Men felt very Brian
singer-based because he had a lot of
power because he's the guy that started
it all like the X-Men one was very
formative it wasn't blade formative but
it was very formative to getting things
moving so I feel like Brian Singer got a
lot of power to change the characters
around but then you've got the problem
of these are iconic characters so we
noticed those differences why is Kitty
Pride using certain powers in Days of
Future Past that wouldn't actually make
sense why is Wolverine the lead of the
X-Men all the time instead of having
cyclops have more than four lines of
dialogue things that are comic fans
expectations are tricky with those
directors but Matthew Vaughn being the
one that actually made the X-Men movie
he got on ceremoniously taken off so I
think he wouldn't sign on to the
authority if he had that kind of like uh
expectation and now he gets to make the
thing he wants to make so I think
there's a lot of benefit in making more
obscure IP but there's also a lot of
benefit fit in making big headline IP
depending on what you want to do as a
Creator absolutely it's well put sir and
uh Hey speaking of
Segways
Mr Segway about Segways it's a segue
about everything and nothing all at once
hold on a second let's see yeah speaking
of uh movies about specific characters
Joker two uh wrapped filming earlier
this week and uh they uh dropped some
new or last week now maybe and they
dropped some new photos to go along with
that I feel like they've had a very kind
of visible uh you know just shooting
schedule or at least they've they've
certainly not it doesn't seem like it's
been too much of a hindrance having a
lot of these images and stuff come out
especially of Harley going down the
courthouse steps and everything like
that and uh and here we've got just a
couple little images I'll uh I'll blow
up really quick we've got one of uh Lady
Gaga as Harley Quinn here as well as one
of Joaquin Phoenix
yeah in the back of a squad car or looks
like a prison bus or something actually
maybe or it could be the interior of a
prison all places Joker would belong or
the hospital something like that
um but yeah I mean the images from this
have been really fun so far and
especially just the amount of
Personality that Lady Gaga has been
showing off especially I mean most of
what I've seen is is from that you know
Courthouse bit
um and then some of her in different
makeups and stuff like that but I think
this is going to be again like when
Joker dropped I wasn't really sure
it needed to continue even though I'm
like it certainly could and I think this
is a really nice way to do that because
I'm like yeah this is the fresh life I
can imagine you know yeah imagine this
being a really messed up Star is Born
you know I am yeah exactly and that's
what I think we're getting and I think
it's really special to tie in the Joker
lore that Todd Phillips made
specifically and that's kind of a unique
example in between the two things I was
describing just now is Todd Phillips got
the leash to make his own Joker Cannon
like that's crazy if you think about it
this is a character that is the biggest
villain in DC maybe the biggest villain
in comic books and it's a movie that's
completely original it's a movie that
doesn't tie into Batman there's a child
Bruce Wayne in it so I'm really excited
for a sequel to a movie that has so much
free reign that the first one made so
much profit because it cost nothing
there's a really unique situation with
Joker too and I think that the boldness
of making it at least partly musical at
least
um you know partly the insanity of
breaking into song because you've cast
Lady Gaga and Joaquin Phoenix who got an
Oscar for walk the line like this is a
man who can sing like Johnny Cash you've
got two incredible singers both
incredible actors playing two iconic
characters in all original Ip this movie
is going to be so special I'm really
excited for it absolutely and we also
have a couple images as well from uh the
upcoming Flash movie uh there have been
some new looks at both Ben Affleck's
Batman but most most namely uh we have a
a quick look at or an image an unmasked
shot of uh Michael Keaton's Batman that
I am pulling I have here somewhere
um here we go this uh shouts out to the
folks over at the direct
um yeah we get a little a little taste
of the unmasked Ketone let's see that
there looking uh you know look cheat me
looking like Dad man
bat dad uh so you know I mean if it's
it's it's still interesting to me that
that even though this has been you know
sort of
um touted as being like this amazing you
know cinematic leap for superhero Cinema
and obviously that's surrounding the
flash it has been kind of a
fascinatingly interesting
I don't there's just so much Batman
coming out of this movie
um I mean Keaton back as Batman is the
headline like it's just it's a it's a
safer headline it's also really exciting
to see Keaton back there's the age of
nostalgia I feel like is waning a bit I
think we're leaving this Nostalgia age
because it's it's not as there will
always be Nostalgia Cinema but I do
think we've hit a threshold where it
won't be like the precedent and so it
feels unique to have something like
Michael Keaton back but not revelatory
but I think the amount he's in this is
going to be revelatory I feel like he's
the second lead and that's exciting yeah
uh very much and I mean you know rest in
peace to the purported uh uh Batman
Beyond movie but uh I'm still I'm very
curious to see what this amounts to
because with again as much as as much
love has been heaped on this movie I
cannot imagine that it is
gonna be you know just like a a silly or
slight thing it seems like it will be a
very impactful role and the flashpoint
story is dark like I feel like there's
going to be some oomph in this one if it
is being regarded as highly as it has
yeah yeah absolutely and actually
speaking of uh of DC actors in general
did you want to touch on some of the
news yeah the new DC uh casting
announcements from James Gunn himself
okay so everyone's talking about Frank
gorillo because he you know talked about
it a month ago and that's been leading
up to this announcement and I feel like
people aren't
qualifying how big these eight
announcements are because this isn't
just the cast of The Corpse Commandos
this isn't just like hey we've got our
eight voices this is the first eight
actors confirmed for the entire DCU
because remember this is a multi-medium
casting decision so it is not only their
voices it is also their video game
um parallel and their live-action
counterpart and all of these actors are
likely going to appear in live action
for these characters and they certainly
look the part every one of these actors
absolutely Nails the visual as well as
their acting tonality uh so we've got
Frank Grillo as can you actually pull
that up for me so I make sure I get them
all right yeah let me agree and also the
uh I want to make sure I don't
mispronounce anyone uh so Frank Grillo
is at the top going to be uh the papa of
Mr Rick Flags we got Rick
senior Mr Frank gorilla which is very
exciting and the being the first cast in
the DCU has made Frank Grillo very happy
which makes me happy so uh seeing Rick
Flex senior here and in the corpse
Commandos and then I assume as well in
live action we've also got the great the
one and only David Harbor as Eric
Frankenstein now if you haven't seen
Frankenstein's monster Dr Frankenstein
on Netflix I do feel like James gotten
watched it and enjoyed that enough to
bring him over and I also think he's
perfect for this role uh David Harbor is
a beast and he's so dryly funny and he's
so charismatic this is a great casting
decision here David Harbor as live
action and voice and video game Dr Eric
Frankenstein uh then we got a Indira
Varma now I know this actresses work I
recognize her but I don't remember where
I know her from so I'm gonna completely
own that but like she absolutely has
that very intense look and the roles I
think if we're in are very intense and
the bride is effectively the lead so
this is a great role for her and I'm
very excited to see her portray it
absolutely sorry let's get rid of this
ad that's taking up the screen uh we've
got one of the best voice actors in the
game and one of the best actors that
doesn't get enough credit for how
multitask talented he is Mr Alan Tudyk
as Dr phosphorus this is Disney's good
luck charm they've literally used him in
every animated movie in the last few in
fact the Disney 100th anniversary film
wish Stars him as a thank you for being
their good luck charm and now he's also
playing Dr phosphorus over WB uh and
that's actually another thing I want to
bring up the weird thing where
everyone's making it like this battle of
like these three MCU Stars left for the
DCU spoiler alert uh David Harbor's
still in Thunderbolts he didn't leave
anything
in both everyone's just gonna have their
big paycheck on one side and their big
paycheck on the other as they have four
years Chris Evans has been like four
superheroes for both sides Ryan Reynolds
has been green landed it's a weird thing
that we're 20 years into the superhero
world and people are like they abandoned
once it's not I know it's a headline I
know you're excited to get your clicks
but don't lie uh so Alan tudex Dr Foster
is very excited absolutely moving on
I'll come back to the mouse there you go
and uh Maria bakalova from Borat 2 also
the voice of Cosmo oh hey what really oh
hey fun so she's going from guardians uh
Cosmo into the yeah right so this is a
very exciting stuff she was the voice in
on the Christmas special lovely okay
that's right yes princess Alana rostovic
don't know this character won't pretend
to excited to see this actress get more
work she is so talented absolutely uh
hey you know
I am an expert on Alana rostovic but I
am going to let you languish out here in
front of the spoiling in the dark fake
nerd who do I think I am and uh Sean
Gunn obviously had to be involved but
he's in dual roles as both GI robot and
we sell which does seemingly confirm the
suicide squad is still Canon which is
exciting uh I imagine because he said no
actor would play roles and like he he
said he's not Lobo and Aquaman but
weasel was in The Suicide Squad so it's
interesting uh I'm just saying that's an
interesting tie in there it must I I
have to you know I mean I guess it must
be that if GI robot were to appear in
live action it's either a makeup or
right so that's the same as weasel I
think they uh it's like I think they can
get around now with Sean Gunn because
weasel is a CG character technically
Sean guns calendar banned in live action
that is true there you go we got his
live action taken we got two voices
Halloween
live action reboot goes up Shawn Gunn
jumps into the Batman yeah absolutely
hey I mean the don't that'll that'll
break the dam
and then everything will be a little it
will be chaos yeah and then Zoe ciao is
Nina mazurski who's got a great uh looks
like Abe's yeah Guillermo del Toro's uh
Abe Sapien flavor going on but I'm
really just excited to see what of these
come to live action and how that
translates
for sure and we got Steve Agee the
biggest announcement boom still playing
John Economist after the hit
actually I won't I won't I won't finish
that just in case anybody is concerned
about spoilers for a certain deceived
film but anyway peacemaker's own Steve
McGee Steve yep is it Aggie uh I have
most reliably heard it is Agy aging okay
but I'll try that I'm trusting comedians
here uh and this is always bold and
those are uh there those are the uh
casting announcements for that project
first eight actors in the DC were locked
absolutely well along with yeah the ones
that we are we know about and uh and hey
just gonna pull this up in here really
quick there's another little Keaton shot
but we we got the uh the Ben Affleck
there's a there's a new Ben Affleck shot
for you looking all intense Batman and
we also have a new shot of uh of uh what
is her name uh Sarah Cali uh Sasha
collie there you go we're close I was
like my brain won't why is it different
yeah looks great yes yeah Supergirl
Supergirl Supergirl Supergirl there you
go super girl woman of Tomorrow is
that's it it's me remember Supergirl
woman of Tomorrow is the comic they're
adapting so it's super girl woman of
tomorrow okay and then there's
Superwoman girl of Tomorrow exactly
that's the weird time travel one they're
gonna make next good excellent
all right well guys let's hop back into
the Super chats really quick actually
let's just see what the regular chat's
doing for just a hot second still
waiting for my polka dot man films uh
yeah absolutely call your boy David come
on
it'll be like hey what are you doing
let's make a polka dot Man movie me and
you you want holes we got dots
uh Hey ooh Iman villani's some Canadian
uh love in the chat as well uh and hey
JR glad that you are able to join us and
that you're not working and contributing
to society here come tripping society
and uh and yeah hey Dr phosphorus live
as well yeah Ben Phillips in the chat
always love Knights tailzone Alan tudik
hey I still gotta see that movie
me and uh yeah every time I see Andrew
Gordon he's like dude we gotta do that
you've never seen a nightstand that is
one of the most formative movies to my
entire existence oh dude like that's
like Lethal Weapon up there that's like
a matrix with a weapon either and now is
the time okay now is the time while
dragged across concrete The Matrix uh uh
either that's coming
are we about to lose our friendship In
Bruges I love him Bruce you've seen
you've seen the Obscure one of the five
like that is a very John thing you'll
find there are 10 movies that shape me I
would argue and like you've not seen
most of them that's gonna be I'm really
curious if you watch them and understand
me more or less like if you like if you
go like what why do you mean this that's
fascinating okay I'm so excited for you
to see any Like A Knight's Tale was like
my entire sexual Awakening like that
movie like taught me so much about how I
felt about the world through a whole
other oh that's what I'm saying man that
movie's gonna be that's like if if you
ever have like a conversation about
movies that shape you that one's like
easily top three that's fascinating dude
I'm so excited to see it oh thank you
thank you for not hating me because I
haven't seen it I'm jealous of anyone
that gets a life experience that I've
enjoyed to such a level getting to have
that at like an age where they can
appreciate it differently like I think
it's really beautiful to like discover
an art at any age so I think it's always
really close-minded to be like why do
you not like have this experience and
then you have an inhere like why make a
negative about something positive ever
but also like if you're about to have an
art experience that's important to you
why why would you judge someone that's
about to have that beautiful moment
happen to them that's such like a lot
little little gem there yeah treat treat
your friends with love and enthusiasm
when they haven't seen a classic that'd
be like I really enjoy chocolate cake oh
you've never had chocolate cake you
better never have it because it's great
like what is you're gonna be a fake fan
now that you're behind the rest of us of
chocolate it's so weird gatekeeping and
antiform is baffling to me but
especially with film because it is
you're about to have two hours that is
gonna change your life that's amazing
what a gift absolutely I I had the
experience multiple times here on this
channel uh most awesome thank you for
the Super Chat contribution very much
appreciate you being here and all of you
guys for chatting away in the chat first
for sending super for just being here at
all especially on this maiden voyage of
John and Coy I have no idea if this will
ever happen again it all depends on how
organized
which in our hands is always going to be
an easy task but most awesome bag of
cats uh going back to uh some of your
comments from earlier ask Men First
Class is my favorite X-Men movies I like
him out awesome I like it and yeah I
think X-Men X-Men first Class is like
terrific and I remember that movie in in
ways I feel like maybe people wouldn't
claim it the best or I'm not used to
hearing people say that but in a lot of
ways when I just think back on the
franchise when you get past like the X2
of it all you're like
first class though was like a moment it
brought it back period piece of it all
like yeah it allowed X-Men to come back
with power and like I don't discredit
Days of Future Past but like there's a
there's an element of first class that's
underappreciated whereas Days of Future
Past gets all the love and then like
apocalypse and everything else but like
there's I think first class obviously
the Eddie guthaggy moment is ridiculous
like Darwin going is dumb but it has
less flaws than the others sure sure uh
A99 Ryan bring back Eddie guthaggy
that's that's the move for Deadpool 3.
okay imagine if Darwin comes back like
that'd be such a great like everyone
else is dying except Darwin you find out
Darwin has survived everything because
he can't die like as it should be so
Eddie guthagi comes back all these years
later that's what I would put him in the
MCU just the he's the first X-Men like
Eddie black he's the only one that
survives the fox Onslaught so Deadpool
kills the whole Fox Universe except
because he's Darwin he's your first
cannon X-Men done Darwin fans harass
the Marvel people on Twitter A99 uh
Multiverse Madness I thank you by the
way for contributing to the conversation
first and foremost the conversation
because that's what we're here to do
Converse Multiverse Madness in
quantumania also had huge potential but
at this point I'm not buying into any
pre-excitement anymore no trailer can
fool me it is what it is
um you know that's fair like I feel like
as movie fans and especially as fans of
this genre that so many of of us and
especially people who have been
following the comics phrases and who are
especially passionate yeah like this has
been a rare opportunity to watch a genre
of Cinema kind of pop off and take hold
of the center stage and uh and yeah
there is I think a wealth of sort of
dizzying excitement that you know kind
of comes with that but yeah you know a
decade or more more than a decade well
more than 15 years of the MCU now uh you
know alone down plus DC like yeah I
think it is reasonable to be at a point
where you're like okay like I've seen
enough of these I understand this this
genre now and people talk about I've
heard some discussions this week about
the idea of uh you know superhero
overload and and stuff like that and I I
think it is sort of a question of any
trailer yeah can look amazing but is
this movie going to give me something
that is fresh or outside the box or like
I heard people talk about Shazam 2 in
particular basically being like this is
not bad it's just like people are used
to this perhaps in a different way and
so it's harder for things to stand out
and yeah I think the hype train also
kind of contributes to that because yeah
it's like these trailers and things are
predicated on being like mind-blowing
and oh my God the anticipation and
there's also like a level of of tenacity
you know amongst the fans of trying to
figure out what all this stuff is and
corresponds to and uh and so yeah I feel
like it can lead to this like maximal
outpouring of energy that comes with all
your enthusiasm and then at the end of
the day it is just like the amalgamation
of a bunch of people's combined efforts
and a movie can go either way so yeah I
mean I feel like I have gotten to a
point in life where I manage my
expectations a lot but certain movies
I'm like nah no matter what happens I'm
just going to let myself be excited and
see what happens like unbridled excited
I uh I feel like every year since
superhero movie started there's never
been more than one or two superhero
films in my top ten like I I love
superhero movies but it's never like my
top 10 isn't just superhero films
because it's a different like experience
to me so the commodification of art is
trailers like you're literally selling
art so a trailer doesn't really impact
my experience one way or the other if
anything like I see the trailer as a
separate piece like it's a different
piece of art than the actual movie and I
unfortunately think it's gotten more and
more ruinous like they've gotten more
and more spoilery they've they've
affected movies negatively in more ways
but I I think that's also like in part
our fan entitlement and expectation and
if it doesn't have this it's not worth
seeing and all those things that
trailers have to be so like I I don't
think a trailer can fool me or not I
just think a trailer is a different
piece of art that often ruins the movie
not enhances it yeah yeah yeah and I
mean you know every trailer has to
attempt to make this look as amazing as
it could possibly look so everything's
supposed to break the internet as
opposed to just being like hey this
movie's coming out you should hear about
it yeah yeah for sure but hey you know I
mean how many how many trailers can we
get with onadamus in them that won't
have her in the actual movie I mean at
least seven more she's actually not in
that uh Chris Evans movie not at all
oh she's the one that is ghosting the
ghost is about her not being in the
movie
see how that turns out I keep seeing the
Billboards this doesn't feel like a real
movie it does feel like a the boys movie
sure it feels like something that is in
universe of the boys that I'm very
curious to see how it plays exactly what
that looks like uh Ryan green thank you
for contributing thank you for your
thoughts and your love and all that good
stuff John and Coy keep being amazing we
will try we are attempting it right now
and I have no idea how it's gonna go but
I'm having a lot of fun being here with
you guys so I appreciate the love also
have y'all seen the new Super Mario
movie not only is it breaking records
but it's close to making one billion
dollars
and this actually kind of relates to a a
topic of conversation that has popped up
in the news this week
um I have not seen Super Mario in fact
uh there's a pretty high likelihood that
a reaction will happen at some point so
keep your eyes peeled for that
um did you see it I did I had a great
time with it it is very very very much a
uh romp like I I definitely found myself
not like gobsmacked by Cinema but I also
found myself very much smiling and
joyous and like invested in what it was
it's visually stunning it's a good time
um yeah I definitely don't think I'll be
watching it like every week but I think
like when it comes on I'll be like ah
Mario I enjoyed that time so yeah I had
a great time with it it makes sense it's
making all the money it is the most like
popular video game of all time I think
so like what a known property to be good
and I'm really happy for illumination
absolutely koi I got one request of you
what do you got
watch the camera oh I keep trying to
read as as intently as the don't don't
try to read the Super Chat here okay
you're over here
insane and this screen is very dim right
now but uh speaking of segue into the
news of the week or at least of the
conversations of the week do you think
people are going crazy right now Mario
is the highest it's the highest grossing
such and such and such and such and it's
also a very high grossing movie in
general uh and the highest of the Year
thus far do you think Guardians will
overtake it that's the people are highly
articulating it might yeah I think it'll
definitely take its spot in
um the the week when it happens but I
think that it'll land just shy of it I
think I think 1.3 to 1.4 Mario and I
think 1.1 to 1.2 we're talking like I
mean that's still 100 million dollars
but like I think they're going to be
very close to each other but I think
Mario is a bit
um
bigger than even a third movie in the
Marvel franchise because how many
generations of people are like the 80s
90s 2000s and today are Mario fans
whereas like so parents bringing their
kids seeing it multiple times I think
Guardians is going to be very very
impactful and sorrowful and I don't know
if that means you know uh it it has the
same like re-watch and you bring 10
people to it I think it's gonna be the
biggest Marvel movie in a long time but
I think at the end of The Run Mario will
be slightly ahead okay that seems like a
like a fair projection I mean Mario is
one of the most ubiquitous care one of
the most ubiquitous characters and has a
gallery of ubiquitous characters and
Groot has gotten huge and Guardians have
gotten huge but like yeah like they're
they're icons now but Mario's been icon
like they've all been icon for four
years yeah absolutely Allison mellow in
the chat where is John John is right
here don't worry he's right here I
haven't gone anywhere
um and hey I'm glad uh Multiverse
Madness delivered for you Dalton Mead
Smith I think you know this has been an
interesting time because some as one of
the as the previous Super Chat from A99
mentioned you know the the big potential
of a Quantum media and a Multiverse of
Madness not feeling so uh uh satisfied
perhaps but I'm glad to see some
Multiverse of Madness love out here and
I'm glad that at least that movie was
able to take some amalgamation of swings
I feel like that's that's kind of what
we're watching with the MCU right now is
watching as they kind of figure out how
to balance you know having that level of
I think I've thought it I think
blockbuster movies in general are always
trying to figure out how do we like
honor the creative voices whilst also
you know making sure we get our
investments back yeah exactly that's the
balance it is Show Business yeah and so
watching the like those two movies
Multiverse Madness and quantumanias feel
like they they were certainly affected
by the modularity of how these films are
made you know oh this plan changed so we
have to change these scenes but also the
pandemic and things like that yeah I
think this will be an interesting phase
because yeah like the Marvels has its
own thing to prove Guardians has its own
thing to send off Deadpool 3 has things
to establish like all of these upcoming
portents are things that have their own
you know really clear-cut just goals to
hit and reasons to be kind of
qualitative just on their own rather
than as a part of a continuum
as the main goal you know it's like
Ant-Man of the Lost Quantum Mania
certainly is more focused on being part
of the Continuum than it is on being a
its own movie yeah uh so yeah but glad
to see some of that love uh El chapani
I'm always aiming for that our role I I
hit it half the time uh but yes uh
Knight's Tale we'll work on it uh we got
we got better ways of dealing with the
music stuff now so it's more likely than
ever before
um oh uh Gilmer Eric Smith in the chat
fan casting Aiza Gonzalez as Wonder
Woman love it and it's funny enough
we've never really discussed this uh uh
but we I did a like like a fan cast of
of my Justice League when we got like
some Patron q and A's and I I believe
through that experience I discovered
that we have the same fan casting for
Wonder Woman do we I oh I don't know if
yours has changed but uh but at the time
we did
yeah yeah yeah I think it should be
terrific she is so good like she's so
good in Andor and she's so like her
presence on red carpets is so powerful
like when I met her for morbius there
was a moment where I was like that's
wonder I'm looking at Wonder Woman Like
I said like and I I don't usually have
fan casts appear before me like usually
I think about it and I think about their
style and I think about like you know
how they play roles and their choices
but like she walked in front of me and I
was like Wonder Woman's here and she is
so perfect I think absolutely but but
Isaac Gonzalez I mean she is also great
and I could definitely see her like she
can throw down certainly and I mean I've
it's funny seeing her from first the
From Dusk Till Dawn series and then
watching as her career is risen in
profile you know she's like she's
definitely seems game to throw down on
the action and the physicality and stuff
like that so uh the armis for zatana
okay I'll chew on that I'm very excited
for a live action zatana whenever that
happens yep uh recent discovery for you
it's been exciting oh yeah and uh hey go
check out our justice league dark uh
reactione because that was an absolute
blast and a half and three quarters
um really quick just want to make sure
that there is not a super chat
pertaining to this there is not um we
also I realized this week have a little
bit of Blade casting we do miss Mia Mia
goth is joining the cast of Blade along
with their uh their new writers and all
that stuff uh how do you feel about that
my guy I think it is very smart to not
only combine the cult horror world that
is Mia goth's playground I'm just gonna
move you past the chat here there you go
not that I don't want to be close but I
understand you got to shove me away I
think Mia gossa I've noticed that Greg
will just instead of waiting she'll just
gonna position you now so I'm going to
try and and emulate that level of
assertiveness part of being in that
chair uh so I think Mia goth brings a
certain clout a certain cult horror
following I think that she's at the
exact right point in her career where
she's very buzzworthy but also talented
like there's a point in your career
where you've done a lot of things that
got you a claim and then you get to make
a lot of money so I I really hope that
this is her getting to like you know
make the money you can't necessarily
make in Cult of horror movies uh I think
it brings an audience and it also to me
shows a tone of what this movie is
because if they're looking for an
actress like Mia goth they're probably
making a cult-ish horror movie I'm also
opening that this uh this restructuring
of Blade with a new writer new director
might spell out an R-rated blade because
I do think blade is one of the only
characters that a lot of characters that
people are making R-rated doesn't need
to be play piss if he's a vampire
there's blood there uh so I I'd like an
R-rated movie so I'm hoping Mia goth is
that so I think this is great casting it
shows a certain tone Choice a certain
following and a certain point of an
actress's career that I want to blow up
so I'm excited absolutely and and at
least the reports are saying that she
would play Lilith Drake daughter of
Dracula so because I've heard Dracula's
in this so that'll be interesting but
maybe maybe it's not Dracula anymore
Nicholas Holton comes in is Boost
Nicholas Cage is Dracula oh my God I
have not seen Renfield it's a blast dude
I'm happy to I'm happy to hear that
because and and I don't
I don't go out of my way to to say these
things unless we're you know being
honest on a video but the trailers I saw
the trailers and I was like oh this
looks like a mess oh it's insane these
trailers are not helping and then to see
the the largely positive and fun
response has been very it took me about
10 minutes to get into the movie because
of how insane it is but I think that's a
hard trailer to cut because the movie's
just bananas yeah like it's Nick Cage at
his cageiest while allowing himself to
draculate up like it's so weird
had a blast and uh yeah glad to see some
of that uh Mia goth love in the chat you
know yeah because I mean it's it's funny
too to watch people's profiles rise
because I feel like there does become
this game of like okay so who's popping
off and who's about to get Snapchat from
which France that's why Billy Magnuson
Booster Gold is perfect Billy Magnuson
has been like right on the edge of super
stardom for a long time and I really
think that he's about to have like three
things in a row like I think he's in
Roadhouse with Jake Gyllenhaal and Conor
McGregor oh dude I'm so excited for
Roadhouse but he's always the guy that's
like oh I love this guy in this thing
and his characterization is exactly
Booster Gold he has that smarm but you
like him he looks like him he and he's
not too big where he doesn't have the
schedule to do the shows but he's big
enough that I want him to be a every one
household name I think I think he's uh
right right at the same point Mia goth
is ooh and uh and and two I'm excited to
see per we finally watched x uh and and
there's a reaction on the channel but uh
but yeah I'm excited to see to see Pearl
uh because yeah I remember I mean seeing
her in uh in that uh oh God the cure for
wellness and then magic oh yeah and then
yeah and she seems she's got that sort
of Tim burtony thing someone wrote in
all caps Sahel akhtar what's your name
what's your favorite character Kristen
Stewart play Polaris uh stoic intense
very focused I can see her being someone
that is like the green hair the gravitas
she runs uh shield in space uh she's
also the daughter of Magneto so she's
got a lot of uh backstory and intensity
and she's got relationships a lot of the
X-Men that are both cantankerous and
loving I think Kristen Stewart uh has so
much more gravitas than she gets to do
in mainstream films um I think she shows
it a lot in her Indie work I'd love to
see her bring that to a mainstream film
so people stop referring to her as like
the actress from Twilight because she's
so much more than that I think that
Patterson is out of that she's still I
feel like she has done the legwork
already to prove that she's she's
transcended Twilight but yeah I feel
like she still needs that big like
everybody now can see here's the billion
dollar version of that people and I
think Patterson did that exactly yeah so
I I personally think she'd be a great
players and uh you mentioned Booster
Gold and Billy Magnuson and it's funny
because because every time you mention
Billy Magnuson I'm like I know I know
that and then I look him up and I'm like
oh yeah that guy uh but uh but somebody
just mentioned Glenn Powell as well
whose profile uh it's the most common
casting choice and mine is no less
stereotypical but I I see
um Glenn as so genuinely likable that I
don't see him as smarmy as booster I
know he's played smarmy he's but even in
the role of
um hangman he was so likable they
couldn't just make him the villain like
even Glenn Powell like they originally
wrote hangman to be more of the
antagonist and he actually uh Glenn
actually originally went out for miles's
role and then they liked Glenn so much
they wrote a new role and then it was
too antagonistic because Glenn's too
likable so there's a there's a thing
about Glenn that's just like he's a
golden age superhero type of guy he's
Hal Jordan like he just is he can
already fly books like him but like it's
his stoic oh wow charm that's a good
call like and I wouldn't want to see I
wouldn't want to see someone that is so
Hal Jordan doing the Booster Gold thing
as funny as Glenn is and as funny and
the community timing and everything if
you haven't seen everybody wants some
you should it's original link later
joint spiritual sequel Dazed and
Confused he's genius in that but to me
I'd rather see uh a golden age hero that
is a little milk toast a little stale
Get Some Love by having an actor that
can add flavor to it then see an actor
play Booster Gold that is too likable
personally fair enough fair enough I
feel that you've convinced me Coy you've
convinced me and uh just a couple other
little chat items before we hop back
into the supers uh D'Angelo Joseph says
protect koi at all costs thank you and
we will do our best to uh I think on the
internet Allison mellow I would love to
see Williams Oh that's Booster Gold I
don't care how old he is that is
I would so I give me that Johnny
Lawrence booster oh I want that so bad
deadly now and I was just him at Megacon
and he is so invested in fandom like he
cares about what the energy of the room
is like he cares about how much the fans
are having a good time he cares about
the moderators experience at a pant like
William zabka is one of the most kind
considerate and funny people I've ever
met like he is such a good person I want
him in everything just because I want
him happy
like it's just like I want the man happy
at all costs okay just a gentle giant of
a lovely man like he's also like Johnny
Larusso like he makes jokes that are
like haha but then he like checks on you
yeah like I love like I so much love for
Zapp oh and uh and uh do you have a pic
for Jean Gray Christian unpronounceable
ones um you know I want them to go uh
younger for Jean Gray because I want
them to start with some uh Marvel
special presentations I think that all
of the X-Men um like a core seven should
get a special presentation where their
Origins told and then a movie should
bring them together so like an hour so
story of Jean Gray of storm of Cyclops
with more than four lines I think those
things to build up to it uh and I think
the girl from Dungeons and Dragons
um I think her name is what is it Sophie
lillis or is that the girl I was about
to say Sophia lillis and I didn't even
realize she was in dungeon's address I
think yeah she's she's it uh she's in it
I forget what that character's name is
now but yes am I am I just mixing up my
redheads though is there because there's
two very talented young redhead
actresses right now that I think both
could crush
um oh no I'm right okay so she's she's
in Dungeon so good oh sure yeah like oh
you're thinking of her or or the girl
stranger things yeah and I and I don't
remember her name so I was afraid thank
you and she was great in in everything
she's done but I think that Sophia
lillis has a little bit more of that uh
can turn like uh on a dime like you can
see the darkness of Phoenix like that
could come and I think that you've
played that long game I think Sophia
lillis is is so talented so young that
I'd like to see her play Jean for like
15 years
she was that was that was the first I
mean you know you were more qualified
but that was my off the Domer yeah so
good so good I'm glad we're on the same
page and never lose your nerd actually
great segue uh we let's get into some
stream Labs right now and thank you guys
uh there is a pin link
um and yeah like any and all
contributions are very much appreciated
streamlabs doesn't take quite as much of
a cut as YouTube so I appreciate you uh
taking the time to jump out of one
platform into another and uh yeah let's
uh let's jump over there real quick uh
never lose your nerd we'll do our best
yeah I can't imagine oh losing your nerd
just just one day waking up and just
being like whoa I am I hate geeky stuff
I hate geeky stuff and I feel like like
losing your nerd truly would mean more
than you expect because I feel like it
would you know you can be a nerd for
anything 100 I think nerd is more it's
not a passions but a Zeal yeah it's
about the cultural perception of you
like there are sports nerds so like yeah
if you just lost your nurse being
apathetic yeah you're like waking up and
being like lackluster yeah you just
might not know you might not care that
much about racquetball or whatever your
thing was anyway but never lose your
nerd but anyway I love Brie Larson and
loved her in Captain Marvel and really
enjoyed the movie I look forward to her
in future projects that's one I'm
curious to watch again because I
remember watching in the theaters and
being relatively positive and you know
in those situations obviously you do
your best not to
a you know with a movie like that it
becomes kind of difficult to assess
because you don't want to let the
discourse affect you very much but at
the same time it's just it's part of the
consciousness of what's happening so uh
so yeah I don't know at the time I I
certainly left the movie being like I
don't get why everybody hates this so
much I actually thought that aspects of
this are kind of unique compared to the
overall of some of the things we've seen
but uh but yeah I'm glad to see some
love for that movie because I don't I
haven't seen it since we watched it in
the theaters and I'm curious to see how
I feel about it on a re-watch I never
watch it before the Marvels as well
because people do often claim it as even
with the vitriol you know factor out
like you said you're like you know it's
just genuinely kind of lower rank pretty
low I guess still making problems with
it sure yeah absolutely and I can see
totally how that would kind of be and
also too how maybe some of the aspects
are a bit on the nose or whatever that
is so I'm curious to to go back and and
kind of assess my my enjoyment of it but
I'm glad that you uh that you are loving
it and that you have that passion for it
and I hope that the that the next movie
can you know live up to that and uh and
surpass it you know even because I gotta
feel like it's a good it's a good
position if they succeed anyway but it's
an even better position if they can like
succeed and also top for the people who
did just always yeah people that were
the Captain Marvel franchise agreed I'm
very and adding mom vlani is always the
right move absolute vodka uh flev Doran
brother flev
Marvel uh uh Enthusiast with a DC
related observation I think hi John and
koi I just started the DC movie
reactions series I've been waiting uh
wanting to watch those films for years
and your reactions gave me the perfect
excuse a lot more fun and informative
watching with you oh thank you sir we
love doing a man they're so much fun uh
very happy people have taken on because
I wanted to keep going and I was like
worried that people would be like okay
you've done like five but like the
people keep loving them so I'm like I
want to do like 80. it is uh it is uh
the one of the like I I shouts out to
Greg she's watching out there but uh but
yeah no when he when when he first came
up with that idea to Paris together uh I
thought it was just gonna be like oh
we're gonna do one of these and then
maybe koi is going to collab with a
whole bunch of people and then it became
this journey that I am intensely
grateful for like I every week I look
forward to these shoots and two I'm
continuing this journey like they're
just such fun movies to take in just as
an enjoyment experience as a viewer but
also they give you great stuff to talk
about they are their own form of of you
know just keeping your mind spry and
aware for all these different you know
uh developments and you get Connor
corrects out of them because you
remember story like for me I remember
storylines I haven't read in years and
for you I can be like oh this character
is this like it inspires a lot of like
nerdy creativity which I really am
enjoying because it expands so much and
there's so I like for years I've heard
how good DC animated movies were and
they're exceeding expectations which is
I could not give it higher praise yeah
yeah like real and and they're they
really exemplify like I know animation
and live action are not
the same when you're conceiving of a
script or whatever but I I do Marvel at
the way that these films are able to you
know tell an hour and 15 20 minutes
story this is so much often times the
best of them have you know the
emotionality the philosophy the action
the fun the fantasy like they're able to
cram all of that stuff in there and you
know I feel like the movies to some
extent could take a little bit of uh and
our next one uh is one of my favorites
oh yeah dude oh so excited for you to
see what's coming next we we're
deviating a little bit from the the
lineage uh but I think I think it'll be
an exciting uh one for people here's an
interesting a little casting bit in the
chat here uh Gilmer Eric Smith says Jay
Ellis as Jon Stewart what do you think
about comedian uh Jay Ellis is I believe
from uh insecure and uh and he will make
sure I know they're right he was in Top
Gun Maverick oh that Jay Ellis I was
thinking Jay Pharoah he's I had the
wrong j no I almost got to pay Jay
Pharoah complimented the she say sam two
person oh yeah but then I didn't get to
but I stood near him and yeah very nice
suit ons I uh I've I've spoken briefly
to both of these Jays once and they
introduced themselves as Jay so my brain
just went to the other Jake uh Jay Ellis
is a very talented man who also learned
to fly because that was Tom Cruise's
mandate so I love the idea of all the
Green Lanterns having pilot licenses
even though Jon Stewart is less of a
pilot uh I think he's very very talented
and also one of those actors that ride
on the cusp of being everywhere uh I
would love if Jon Stewart had the
ability to elevate a very talented actor
to household name uh I think there's a
lot of actors that could play Jon
Stewart but there's only a few that
could Master the amount of leadership
um occasional arrogance that's that
causes problems um likability while
having those flaws uh there's a lot to
Jon Stewart so I would love someone uh
like this to to crush it so yeah love
that idea yeah I've been like I said I I
started watching insecure back when that
first season dropped just on a whim and
and got it was just very enthralled by
it and he's one of the main characters
of that show and ever since then it's
been fun to watch his Star Rise watch
him go to escape room and then top gun
Maverick and all these other things so
uh yeah I'm definitely rooting for him
and and you know I mean again I defer to
you for these matters but I think I mean
just just from the experiences I've had
with the character of Jon Stewart and
and from his chops I feel like if he
bulked up you know I feel like he could
be a really cool like I always go John
boyega sure I want John boy because
Redemption franchise Redemption
absolutely like justice for boyega give
him that truly one of the guys that I
really think should get cast in
something as an apology like he's so
talented and Kevin Henry Cavill like a
buddy movie like anything that's gonna
be like hey this is gonna make a billion
here's five percent of the back like
just like he's so talented and he got so
publicly screwed and he's like you get
you give a guy a role where he's like
hey you're gonna be a stormtrooper that
becomes a Jedi but then we're not gonna
do that
how do you feel that I saw a
tweet just this week I can't I can't
remember if it was David Ayer tweeting
it or just him retweeting and responding
to it I think it was David air but but
somebody basically said like where's the
you know like gritty you know storm
troop from the Stormtrooper POV like you
know grunt Soldier movie yeah and he was
like yeah do that because I mean you
know David Aire Fury it makes sense and
I'm like yeah like give John boyega that
movie like what what yeah like that that
iconic moment from the teaser uh for the
force awakens where he comes over the
Ridge and he pulls his helmet off and he
looks so desperate like what led to that
I want that Star Wars movie like that I
want him in Andor I want him in that
yeah watch him wake up from the the
Imperial indoctrination and and you know
sort of see the seeds like you know
doing Andor but
yeah certainly would have a different
political inclination than Andor but you
could do something really worthwhile I
love my I guess to her because that does
give him that like here's your franchise
we're gonna be over here we're sorry and
you're great because he's also wicked
talented and he seems like a really good
guy I like where he stands a lot of
issues and I like how outspoken he is
about a lot of things big fan of that
guy no he keeps it real him that or I
could I could also see him as maybe like
a cyborg oh yeah not to just be like any
black character but but I can see the
the build and the personality of both of
those guys I can see him to me it's it's
boy I guess humor is very cyborg the way
he is in interviews the way he carries
himself I like the athleticism of like
the cyborg character before he becomes
cyborg for boyega I see all that uh now
really quick uh is the chat does a want
to know right before we're gonna hop
back into Super chats
um but
what do you think just at the moment not
going to spend too much time on this but
uh Larry Allen asks who will be king
once Jonathan Majors gets fired I I'm
not going to go so far as to as to
double down on your assertion that he
will certainly be fired but what do you
think of the situation as it stands now
are there at least reports of like
they're talk this week at least there
have been Rumblings of Marvel's talking
about him and some people seem to think
that that means of firing some people
seem to think that it's just of course
they're talking because the situation
isn't resolved uh I talked about this
briefly on the big thing uh oh and by
the way uh if you're in La I'm doing
stand up on the 28th with the big thing
of Christian all those guys at Flappers
so if you want to see my stand up you
want to see us do a show over there go
get flapping that's gonna be fun but uh
we talked about this briefly or not
briefly it was unfortunately a long talk
on the big thing because the internet is
uh very interesting in that when I said
I believe women they thought that was a
controversial statement
um I think it's really important to look
at this as something that is unknown I'm
a huge fan of Jonathan majors and I am
in a very tricky position looking at
this situation because every time I see
someone on Twitter go like this thing
happened at Yale then there's no one
backing it up it's like one guy and then
it's like a week later like one other
person that have nothing to to like I
feel like his reputation is being tossed
around in a way that that is like an
Open Secret of his reputation that I've
seen nothing to back up but at the same
time a woman might have been hurt and
that is never acceptable so I'm in the
position of if it happened there have to
be ramifications if it didn't happen how
do you prove the absence of something I
I am a very innocent until proven guilty
person but I'm also a very a woman
getting hurt in that situation is always
up against a lot of odds because so many
people get hurt um there's so much
domestic violence in this in in every
country there's so much domestic
violence that goes unreported because of
what it does to demonize uh uh women in
particular so if it happened I wouldn't
want there to be no ramifications but if
it didn't happen I wouldn't want someone
as they're coming up that is that
talented that seems to be that good of a
guy to be punished because of something
that didn't occur so this is a no-win
scenario I don't even like talking about
X we don't have enough facts yet and
honestly it's been really gross
um to see either side leap to a decision
decision in their own mind of this is
what should happen this you weren't
there I guarantee it and you don't have
enough facts I can almost guarantee it
unless you're working the case if you're
the D.A and you're in the chat you let
me know but unless you have enough facts
it's a really gross thing to make any
assumption any direction so I'm very
consciously neutral with the side of
it's really messed up if it occurred
it's really messed up if it didn't occur
that this is occurring so I really hope
we can find facts like fact facts I I
don't know if that's a non-answer but
it's just it's a mess that this is
happening here's a fact Michael dahman
in the chat says art will save the world
go visit a museum soon I like that dude
I love that I I definitely think art is
um the thing that separates us from
machines and that AI is making art that
people are purchasing is kind of the
most
um dystopian future thing I've lived
through yet and that's saying a lot
because I was born when I was and I've
lived through 30 years this chaos but I
think art is is what makes you feel and
separates you from
non-sentient thought and I think art is
the only thing that really brings us
together as a species so I think that
visiting museums celebrating our
experiencing communal art experiences
whether that's a concert or a movie or
any of those things is the thing that
we're missing the thing we defund in in
fascism is Art in schools the thing they
don't want you to do is learn and and
gain knowledge but they also in addition
to not wanting you to learn and get
knowledge is they don't want you to
appreciate art they being people that
are taking away yeah like critical eye
exactly they don't want like the growth
of you as a person so doing what you can
to grow as a person is always what I
suggest for people to uh to be better
grow get those emotional gains and hey
Bryce Burris Apparently one of our
comments or one of these comments in the
chat led to your super chat so that
makes for a perfect seg
way into we'll get we'll get there we're
doing these linearly but uh but segue
back to the super chats at very least
and uh film it Lee thank you for your
country tribution for joining us on a
Saturday hey hope you guys are well I
was wondering if you guys have seen
Barry yet on HBO Max and that actually
leads us to another news item right just
curious because the final season starts
tomorrow it's a criminally underrated
show I've I have caught moments and
Snippets from Barry uh but I am very
excited to do a full and comprehensive
watch Greg has raved about it over time
and uh every little snippet I've seen
has been
fascinating and delightful and and
intense and uh yeah I very excited but I
haven't seen it just yet but uh you know
now that it's coming to an end I guess I
have no excuse but to catch back up uh
and uh have you seen any Barry I don't
love it
I uh leave coach I I know I I just said
uh I don't like to talk negatively about
art but if someone asks uh I just like I
uh I give a show um three or four
episodes because there's so much good TV
and there's so many good movies to watch
that I I try a long enough time that I
feel like is Justified and it's usually
three or four episodes and it just
wasn't my humor uh I something about it
just didn't strike I like everyone
involved I'm especially a big fan of
Henry Winkler but I I just couldn't find
a connectivity and I couldn't find
something that made me laugh enough to
keep going so I love how much people
that love Barry are always like it's
underrated it's funny because I'm like
is it underrated because everyone I know
loves it but I I don't know what the
ratings are it is something that a lot
of people admire and appreciate love
it's just not my cup of tea fair enough
koi and uh what I think we might be able
to both agree on is is the new name of
the discovery Warner streaming service
your cup of tea koi are you excited to
spend all of your time watching Max you
know X the Goofy movie every time
like that's the only good thing to come
out of this is that people are talking
about Goofy movie uh I think that it is
a very short-sighted idea to not lean
into the Warner Brothers brand which is
100 years old one of the oldest studios
in the world nah man we erased Fox from
the map we could do that too I it's so
weird because branding is fought over
years and quality like you get a brand
by earning it and so it's really weird
that the HBO brand which is quality
television and the Warner Brothers brand
which I think of as movies but obviously
has great tv as well Warner Brothers is
Lethal Weapon The Matrix like Warner
Brothers is so many things that I've
loved since I was born and to get rid of
both of those things to be like let's
call it the most vague version of plus
possible everything tried to be plus and
then the pluses got taken so they made
it a Max and now they got rid of the
thing that made the max the Max and now
it's just max it is preposterous and I
do think it's I mean people have pitched
like you call it like Warner Max or
something like that which I thought that
was a decent solution but also like I
don't know HBO carries such a weight as
a name like HBO and it's and it's Warner
and Discovery together like it it almost
seems like having this middle entity
that already carries all of this clout
would be ideal but it's what do I
Preposterous yeah this is a real meme
it's called HBO yes it's right freaking
HBO but you know what they are getting
pressed not the Press they want but at
least people are talking about it sure
sure absolutely oh my I'm not gonna
bring it up
so there was something that happened
yesterday that that brought every single
person out of the Twitter would work to
be disappointed on two opposite sides of
an issue but like with the same
disappointment which I thought was very
funny I had no idea what this moment is
you're gonna we cannot we cannot tangent
this okay but I will say Anheuser-Busch
put out a statement yeah literally all
the people on the Progressive side and
all the people on the anti-lgbtq side
were both like this statement says
nothing IT addresses no side it seemed
like all you're doing is going like hey
these are one of me specifically the CEO
of this company and so yeah that's how
you bring people together it was a big
apologies yeah I was like weirdly
everyone's United
cool too oh you're the you you're the
first cool and everyone is cool too
around you okay goose and flirkin
kitties are here to save the MCU do you
think the flirtkins will I mean ignite
us like an Anheuser apology uh I think
the flirtkins are a great equalizer and
I I think flirtkins are beloved and I am
a little biased because Goose looks just
like Spidey cat so I got a lot of flirt
and love because my baby boy is now a
Funko and I like literally ah Khan I
worked at gave me a goose Funko because
he looked like Spidey and they knew my
cat so I was like I am forever endeared
to this animal and I think animals in
movies are whether you're heartless or
not something gets you it's like a core
genetic marker that we feel for animals
so it's a smart move absolutely got it I
mean and we're gonna have like an army
of them so get that merch but also who
knows I mean they took out Nick Fury's
eye and that's going to be a bigger
moment I think there's something about
the flirkin marking Nick Fury that is
gonna make the difference between him
and a squirrel him I think something
happens with the flirkin where it was a
way that the flurkin was aware of the
cree scroll War to come and that moment
is going to be a big deal in the Marvels
I've got this theory that the scratch is
the thing that ties secret Invasion to
the Marvels that's a good call too you
heard it here first I like it all right
um okay let's see who's next Jeff the
Maverick hey guys love the DC animated
reactions thank you so much for the love
we love doing them uh but an unrelated
question good John are you going to do
more Demon Slayer uh season two and
three reactions the animation is unreal
yes
um I'm not sure exactly how we're going
to proceed because uh uh I mean at least
on patreon Greg did express some
interest in joining me for season three
but uh reactions for the first two
seasons are all up on patreon aside from
the movie The moogan Train movie which
is here on YouTube in in its highlights
form
um but yeah definitely going to be
continuing uh season three uh as soon as
possible just a matter of what the
arrangements become but uh but yeah the
animation on that show alone and just
like the way that they're able to yeah I
mean in a way it's quintessentially
anime but the way they are able to bring
out just the intensity of the expression
via the animation is is really
breathtaking uh on that particular
series and I cannot wait to continue
should check it out sometime coach
somebody shows all the shows clear your
schedule man just watch don't talk I
looked at my list of shows and I have 27
shows on the must watch and I'm up to
482 movies I like everybody says like oh
it's on my list I actually have a list I
have a list and that's big oh no when I
counted oh God I I pray for you I've I
shudder to imagine what my list of
Amalgamated shows I need to see would
possibly look like I'm two respawn and
Ted lassos you know it's bad my favorite
show on air I'm behind them that's how
that's how dire it's gotten still gotta
start season six behind on Amanda
raccoon oh you got you got treats ahead
of you boy a raccoon shampoo if they did
Clayface in the Batman Universe do you
think they could do some sort of take on
deep fakes or find some other way to
manifest his shape-shifting abilities in
a realistic way that's a really cool
question raccoon shampoo it's funny
because
uh from what I understand
perhaps the original or I know Clayface
has many takes and and origins in the
comics but one of them as somebody
brought up I believe last week when we
first talked about the idea of Clayface
being in the Batman 2 was that you maybe
they'll go with that more traditional
like he's a an actor with many disguises
and wardrobes and things like that and
to me
I think that could be fun and
interesting but there's also something
like the Matt Reeves University occupies
this space where it's grounded but
there's like a little bit of room for
height and I feel like there's also a
certain thing at least not to hold all
of his Batman movies to this standard
but the Riddler take suggested to me
that yeah they're interested in
mirroring aspects of our time and
aspects of the just tone of our of the
world we live in now and so I think
something with Clayface and deep fakes
or or some kind of
the uh digital Amalgamated element could
be an interesting way to bend the
character and then I always my mind
always goes to like those classic film
Noir things of like you know you changed
your face it's not like having some kind
of weird heightened like plastic surgery
angle or something like that you know
going with uh I always think of dark
passage but you know uh uh Marv and Sin
City kind of Harkens directly to that
you know I think they're going to do
something like they did with Mysterio uh
and make it like a futurist villain
because I I do think the idea of a deep
fake is something very present I think
that uh the Riddler represented exactly
when that movie came out and and then
like five years earlier uh I think we've
got like the problem with trolls and and
people feeling like Outsiders banding
together and Vengeance being people's
main motivation and you know I love that
that movie goes from Batman being
Vengeance to Batman being hope and I
think that's a really important Arc for
people that are just full of Rage I also
think we're entering an age of
misinformation to a scale that will
never come back from I think that we're
going into much the same way that
vengeance is a present day problem I
think that if you look at the flaws with
culture and Community is it we're all
really angry we all all of us feel like
we're being slighted all of us feel like
we're being wronged by an a thing and so
that is the Riddler I think that the
next thing we're about to deal with is
We're Not Gonna know what our reality is
very soon we are already entering an age
where AI voice over is is
it's so close to not recognizable like
there are times I can't tell and I'm
really focused on this stuff there are
imagery uh uses that are already to the
point where it's almost it's not quite
there you can tell sometimes the eyes
sometimes some of the framework but if
that's the stuff we're already seeing
that means that within a year it's going
to be unrecognizable I think that this
is the last election that we're gonna
actually know what's real and what isn't
and that's still got an asterisk for me
I think there's going to be a lot of
people using these tools for much bigger
things than entertainment so I think
it's a really smart idea to have a
character like Clayface represent the
real world problems of we don't know how
bad things are about to get for trust
for um belief in systems bigger than
ourselves for talking to people you're
not in the actual room with we're going
to be at a point in the next five years
where someone can call you on FaceTime
and you might think it's your mom and
it's not like we're about to enter a
really terrifying time or first Headroom
timeline voicemails are going to be uh
useless sure texts are already useless
because obviously you don't see the
person writing it but it's going to be
as vague as a text and that's that's a
around the corner so I think in the same
way like he said the Riddler being about
the time I think Clayface can represent
that I think it's a really important
thing when dealing with the Batman who
represents identities a lot of people's
big complaint about the first the Batman
was Bruce Wayne wasn't in it enough
that's because Bruce Wayne doesn't exist
yet in this continuity Bruce Wayne isn't
formed because he makes the mask that is
Bruce Wayne to cope with Society in this
world he's a recluse in a cave he hasn't
made the public Persona of Bruce Wayne
yet so that's going to be the mask he
develops what better character to
parallel Bruce Wayne making his mask
than Clayface an absolute vodka real
quick from the chat uh Gilmer Eric Smith
says Luke Evans is Batman and Jared
Harris's Alfred I will take Jared Harris
in anything all right I love Jared
Harris and uh I would like it I was I
would check out his Alpha for sure I'm
gonna throw you a real quickie before we
hop back into some super chats but uh
Marvel Comics Virtual Reality Fitness as
Marvel Comics are better than the movies
agree disagree go uh I think that
different genres every different
strengths I think that the movies I know
that's a lawyer answer but I think the
movies allow for you to connect with an
actor's history that you have with the
actor when an actor is playing a role it
allows you to go like oh I love that
person or oh I love their other work and
you consciously or subconsciously
connect to the character because of the
actor I think comic books are a
different medium where you get the
strength of the writer and the artist
directly communicating to your soul
there's less Cooks but because of that
some people don't connect and therefore
you're not if you don't like the first
comic you pick up with a character
sometimes you stop and whereas a movie
you've got a lot more data to play with
so I think that Marvel Comics and Marvel
movies can't really be compared because
they're playing on different aspects of
your personality for sure uh annalize
annalize
Cirque squill I'm trying so hard I'm
sorry uh but uh wants to see Professor
pig in the Batman too uh yeah I've
actually got a fan cast for that who
who's I think Hayden Christensen would
be really fun because he's got such a
Darkness to him but he's he's got an
inherent handsomeness so I love the idea
of someone trying to make people into
these Abominations with the darkness
that they have and I think that I'd love
to see Hayden much like actually much
like John boyega I want a Redemption
like I want him to get a franchise or
I'm like some love on him which which
you know Obi-Wan attempt to dabble it
but but yeah but out of that yeah yeah
you want the dunk and uh oh that's right
uh Bryce Burris uh the boys season four
just wrapped filming excited I saw the
Jack Quaid looking all bloody and give
it a thumbs up yeah and uh Louis Barry
says uh if not irons would love to see a
Richard E Grant that's Alfred uh I love
that and uh space uh space man up there
koi is spitting I got Clayface thoughts
yes he is uh hold that Clayface thought
I'm sure we can address it
um but hey let's look at film Italy back
in the soups
oh man
thank you for contributing did you guys
manage to watch Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves it's surprisingly
good and hope it doesn't flop would love
more DND movies I feel like that would
probably be a reaction for this channel
so I have not seen it as of yet you have
seen it I loved it I'm so excited I've
heard nothing but good uh I saw it I
actually interviewed the writer director
Duo uh John Goldstein and John Francis
Daly who are delightful we actually have
like a full 20 minute chat which was
really really wonderful I usually
usually jump into like four minutes you
have two questions leave uh so I
actually got to talk with these guys
which was wonderful because I consider
them in Lord and Miller meta modernist
Masters and meta modernism is a study of
art that means the world to me I
reference it a lot it's kind of my
favorite thing in culture right now and
these guys I feel like with game night
with this with their take on Cloudy with
a Chance of Meatballs 2 have really
figured out how to be futurists with
comedy comedy is a really hard thing
especially right now because uh comedy
is something that is such a piece of
taking a snapshot of the time it's
released that's why people are like oh
that wouldn't get made today it's not
about that it's because that was what
the culture was at the time so I think
they are uniquely good at thinking a
year ahead and I think Dungeons and
Dragons is as impactful as the Kelvin
Universe Star Trek film was whether you
like that film or not it changed how
movies were made it changed the impacts
of a lot of things and I think Dungeons
and Dragons which was number one in the
box office for the first week and I
think a half uh is exceedingly uh doing
well because they're able to see that
turn and I think it's one of the best
franchise starters I've seen in years
very good and this is someone that has
best friends in Dungeons and Dragons
that has never played it and I know a
lot of people think I'd be great at it
which I take as a compliment but I have
37 shows to watch I'm I'm excited to
finally Play Someday I I really am I
I've I've heard people first timers in
fact I think Greg a few months ago came
back and was like I played for the first
time and it seemed daunting at first but
it was a lot of fun so yeah I'm very
yeah I feel like that's the art form is
like you need somebody who can jump you
in with like a here's a not too
overwhelming story or whatever yeah but
yeah and I get this is just a gut
feeling because I know that there's been
some speculation of like is it doing
well enough to get a sequel but
something just feels to me like enough
people like this there's enough like
positive energy surrounding the people
involved with the movie the people
taking in the movie I feel like the
franchise itself has potential to be one
of those that yeah it doesn't make like
the craziest Financial dunk but does
well enough to be like nah let's let's
bolster this and do some more everyone
seems so happy making it it feels like
yes and the movie like it feels like
people were having joy and improv which
is impressive to film a thing that feels
like the script was improv that somehow
the visual effects are improv they
actually like it's impossible for it to
be improv and yet it has that
spontaneity which makes the joy of
watching it and the joy of being on set
magic I love that um Ariane Kanani in
the chat uh I don't know I'll try to get
all the Facebook moms to stop uh
thinking it's on you it's on you also
have a review up on my YouTube page
which I never plug on here because I'm
at reject Nation but I do have reviews
up for stuff that I don't do with these
guys over there watch 10 koi videos on
this channel and then go watch one video
on koi that's a fair balance I support
that that's the the ratio we're aiming
for here donkey teeth
that uh if that's a key and peel
reference I'm here for it all day every
day uh I do Wonder at what point are
there too many Heroes to do them all
Justice I want to see every hero in live
action but how many is too many is there
a too many
I I'm very curious about this because I
feel like we are at an interesting
Crossroads in in that more than ever
what's fun and cool is that we are
having to dig past the most obvious and
most iconic characters uh which I think
can highlight both the breadth of
imagination but also the breadth of
overlap
um so I think it'll I don't know I think
that ultimately any
it always comes back to me that any
character can be done Justice with just
the right take and the right approach so
part of me feels like I mean yeah you
could theoretically bring in as many as
you want if it worked in the comics I
feel like it can work on screen and I
feel like they've translated there are a
lot of ways in which these TV shows and
movies have come great strides in
emulating how comic storytelling Works
um but yeah I don't know what do you
think I think that uh there's a movie
coming out this year called the killer
it is David Fincher directing uh Michael
Fassbender and uh Tilda Swinton I
believe and nobody knows it's a comic
movie and that's okay because it is a
David Fincher movie about a French comic
and that my example there is that it
doesn't have to be known to be a comic
movie it is a medium that's being
adapted you don't like I've never heard
a single person in the history of
filmmaking go you know there's too many
movies based on books like it's it's
just like anything else it's a thing
that is a story that someone demands to
make into a new medium there is no
reason reason to think that any medium
being translated into another medium
have you ever thought man there's too
many samples in hip-hop no songs turn
into other things things evolve things
get remixed I don't like that there's
too much of jazz in my rock like that's
not how it works it's an evolution of a
medium so I don't think um that's the
case I do think a style of adaptation to
superhero is a problem I think that if
everything looks the same if everything
feels the same if everything has a
three-act jungian structure if
everything feels like you know how it's
going to end that's a problem but that's
a problem in all movies that's a problem
in movies because we're battling this
constant thread of I want to know what
happens next which is why trailers with
spoilers do well versus I want to be
surprised by the experience and thus
you've got to fight these two things so
film often juggles that familiarity with
the uncertainty so I don't think it's
about making Comic characters I think
it's about making good characters
absolutely well yeah and I mean you know
I think that's ultimately what I think
people get lost in the weeds sometimes I
think it's George R I'm sure many people
have said this I think it was George RR
Martin in the anecdote I'm about to
relate but people you know asking like
how do you write such and such a kind of
character I think in this particular
instance it was how do you write strong
female characters
and the piece of advice was just like
write a good character just just imagine
your character is just a human and write
them as best you can and that's how you
do it yeah so yeah at a certain point
yeah you know you just write a character
uh if you follow it up I want to make
sure we give that credit uh I meant more
of uh if you introduce every character
in comics in the live action you can't
do it of shows and movies to keep them
all alive so to speak uh I I that that I
I totally understand what you're saying
there I do think that um you need to
give a character enough time to be good
I use Cyclops as an example all the time
because Cyclops is a very very well
fleshed out character when the right
writer writes him but even in the comic
books he's not fleshed out enough a lot
of the time so it needs to be a um a
focus on what you want that character to
do as the tapestry of the whole movie if
you want them to be a lead yeah they
need more than that but we're also
getting shows and movies there's plenty
of time I don't think every character to
be adapted because Comics have been
around for 60 years but I I see you're
saying like mainstream characters and
whatnot I think they need to focus on
what the story is they're trying to tell
multiversely and singularly before they
decide who to adapt and be loyal to that
story and that's that's mapping the 10
years out like Evan feige had been doing
and I think the timing of expanding the
Multiverse hitting alongside a real-life
pandemic threw that off but I think it's
coming back together absolutely Louis
Berry
hoped to get thank you also by the way
for for hanging out with us and for
contributing to the chat I hope to get
cavill's soups and momoa's Aquaman
cameos in the flash with Pfeiffer's
Catwoman cages soups and a Wilson Bethel
as reverse flash Wilson Bethel that's
fun he's uh Bullseye okay okay sure yeah
he's a fantastic actor went out for
Captain America it always fascinates me
he was almost happier she put the suit
on Alternate timeline boy uh I mean what
do you think the likelihoods of all
these things are I'd say cavil soups is
is unlikely
um I think uh anything that's shot and
it's out there but we'll never see it
yeah yeah that's gotta have been cut
ages ago I think mimo's Aquaman's gonna
get screened first and we'll see how the
screening goes uh I think that uh
Pfeiffer's Catwoman is very unlikely but
I would be very happy like I would like
that's the one I want most as much as I
love Cavill I just don't think it's
gonna happen I want Pfeiffer's Catwoman
most uh cage the soups is a reserved for
Teen Titans but uh I love this I love
this support I I I'm I cater soups all
day I I don't feel like it'll be cheeky
enough to go with that um
but weirdly I could see it being the
kind of thing where like the Michelle
Pfeiffer Catwoman if she doesn't appear
I could foresee them doing some kind of
cheeky thing where it's like a photo
yeah or Michael Keaton mentions her off
hand or or like when he exits the
picture in one way or another like she's
often I I hope that they stay together
my head Cannon is Tim Burton Catwoman
Bruce for days oh dude oh man that that
is just a magic portrayal Michelle
Pfeiffer like like the only thing that
makes me wonder is if they really were
developing that Batman Beyond movie I
could see maybe her being involved in
somewhere but wishful thinking man
that's all it is right now uh Jeff
Carroll
one of four oh here we go first
critics of the Marvel's Iman vilani is a
national Treasurer so shut up so if
you're in the chat critiquing you heard
what he said yeah second your thoughts
on some of my fan casts here we go
Marvel
Angela Catherine winick
uh interesting and Beta Ray Bill
Christopher Judge yo Angela who's the
boss I really like your Catherine
Winnick
um I want Beta Ray Bill to have like
some extreme accent uh but like I I
honestly wanted Christian Bale to play
beta Rebel because I thought Christian
Bale being real now Welsh accent like
that'd be really fun for a Welsh Beta
Ray Bill uh so I I Christopher Judge
Works in that vein but it's not quite
What I Hear personally uh but Catherine
Winnick as Angela I adore because she is
very talented and very intense and
wonderful absolute vodka let me see here
really quick uh okay so Jeff definitely
hard on the paint like that is that is
an intense Bevy okay let's keep it going
um
no let's let's do oh really quick okay
this is just this is just some love I
believe uh bo Sumner uh really quick
before we get back to Jeff hey guys and
thank you for this very generous uh
contribution as well so thank you for
joining us uh hey guys I just wanted to
say I love your enthusiasm and kindness
I use yeah oh yeah you like kindness
who do you think you are inserts uh
ironic joke here uh I use a wheelchair
so movies are my escape and seeing your
love for movies makes me feel better
about loving movies so much all that
that means the world thank you I'm
that's the goal I mean you know even
here yeah even when the topic of
conversation isn't always the most
positive at the same time I feel like
yeah we we do try to lead with that love
and I'm and I'm glad that it
communicates and I'm glad that yeah I
mean I'm glad that you're able to you
know engage in such a vivid passion you
know and and to share that with us means
a lot you know and uh and yeah just uh
the fact that movies are able to to
bring you some of that relief to in that
escape and that you know color you know
I'm I'm glad that we can kind of commune
around that I think the internet should
be that right like I think passion and
anything that's like coming from a place
of good anything that's not harming
others anything that's not violent
anything that's like a net positive if
you can find more passion in finding
other people connecting through the
power of the internet to find more
passion about anything that's the
beautiful thing that this weird
technology should be is just finding
more joy digitally every day so I'm
honored we can do that for you did you
Joy
Joel all right two of four for Jeff
Carroll here we go all right we got we
got Dr Doom Hugh Laurie or Jeremy Strong
you know I like both of those I do feel
like Hugh Laurie uh is a little bit
I don't know if I buy the physicality
you could obviously just do the voice he
could be in another suit but I kind of
would love if whoever is in it is both
because like the way you emote when
you're moving in a frame sometimes you
can tell someone's voice acting like
even if they're moving in the booth I
would I want someone physically there uh
and doom is Doom uh so I I really I
think I want someone uh physically in
the space that also is the voice so
that's personally my take there Jeremy
Strong is just going to be on set
pissing Brian Cox off just just
antagonize it acting Shenanigans I'd be
curious yeah I feel like Hugh Laurie
might be a little he might be a little
too old I feel like I don't know like
Jeremy Strong I think would be
interesting I I feel like his character
the bits of succession I've seen he's
just like a he's such a weasel yeah like
Doom is the opposite yeah yeah yeah and
not to say he can't play that sure but
but yeah I I I it would be a pleasant
surprise to see the take you know come
to life if he were to be cast night
crawler Tom Lush this person I do not
know I'm gonna totally own that I I will
I will not claim Tom
all the vowels again very cool name
absolutely always a German actor oh yeah
yes all right a man has no name yeah
he's cool as hell and uh homie from
stranger things four as well and he was
so good and stranger things like he was
so captivating I mean he loved him yeah
uh I I always saw Nightcrawler younger
um this dude you know is going to be
starting uh he was born in 73. uh I
think they're gonna go uh I mean I could
see them doing the Claremont era
um reimagining of X-Men as like some of
the teachers and then that would totally
work but I really want like I said the
top to have a younger cast we grow up
with uh like like Harry Potter and then
we sat on your Taylor joy for Polaris
you know Anita was so perfect as magic
man like I wanted to just like somehow
come back she was perfect okay okay and
Polaris is Kristen Stewart but if not
then she's great and then saber tooth
Alexander Skarsgard you see that
especially after the northmen with that
build he got like he is out absolutely
ready for that yeah tell you what I got
to train with uh his trainer
um no wonder no this was brought to you
by the Northman uh no like soon I mean
soon you and Greg are going to be in
these in these news chats just like
full-on like oiled tank tops just like
looking like you're a Muscle Beach or
some some like you know it's funny
a while ago uh I did a photo shoot that
is me like flexing shirtless that looks
just like the beast from uh James McAvoy
and someone put them together and it's
like one of the things that pop up when
you Google me like it was popular enough
it took off but I didn't realize that
Magnus Rideback who I trained with very
briefly uh is the guy that trained
McEvoy for the Beast so in Florida he
and I were talking about Magnus like we
started talking about physiques and
build and Magnus came up and I was like
this is an insane moment where I'm
talking to the guy that I got memed
about about our physiques about our
physiques and Magnus so uh shout out to
Magnus it was a moment absolutely oh my
god dude Tiny World What A Moment Like
insane oh yeah Maca boys over there
koi toad Kieran Culkin that's fun love
that that's great that's a solid one man
these are good do you know what happens
to a toad when I get struck it turns
into a Culkin it does
and it's been fun to see his start yeah
the rise to a wolverine Pilgrim love too
yeah oh my God that was the first movie
that really kind of clicked him in my
mind and he's so great yeah oh my God I
love his his dead pannedness in that
movie Wolverine Jensen Ackles okay I I
you'll have more comprehensive thoughts
about this I feel like I I like the idea
a lot but I don't know if I don't I
don't know I'm not sure
I love all your casting I'm gonna I'm
gonna preface that but Jensen Ackles
will have the same issue with he's
Wolverine should look like he smells
awful Wolverine should like he just
should be repugnant but somehow like you
want like Gene still has to lust after
him but because he's the dichotomy of
Cyclops it should be like I know this is
bad I know this is wrong but it's his
darkness and his Edge and his feralness
that calls to me he should look stinky
Jensen Ackles is actually a really great
Cyclops like Jensen Ackles would be a
great and the leading man that has a
little darkness that is always going to
choose to be the leader even at cost and
so I think Jensen Knuckles be a great
Batman he'd be a great Cyclops but he's
got a little bit too much of that I'm
All-American like perfect to be a guy
that says believably to me I want him
cigar chomping feral Harry
I just love all these descriptors but
great cast yeah yeah and it's funny I
hadn't considered who would you say uh
Edgar Ramirez is mine uh yeah we talked
about that and I know he's a little tall
but who'd you say Jensen Ackles should
play that's not Batman uh Cyclops that
was I think it's incredible because
that's the thing is is for him like I'm
used to Dean Winchester and stuff like
that and obviously soldier boy now but I
feel like I would want if he jumps into
one of these universes I would want it
to be something a little Cyclops sounds
like the less like like I heard you say
that and I went oh you know whereas
whereas Wolverine it feels like okay
parts of this feel like yeah like a not
an obvious choice but yeah just like one
of those names that would be thrown
around for this but who my metal
detector says not not quite not quite
perfect could do it certainly I would
enjoy watching but not quite clicking
them and by the way Edgar Romero smells
lovely we did stunts once together he's
perfectly but he looks like smelled
better after the stuff that she just is
an aromatic disc but he also like looks
like some guy that if he if you see an
opening shot of him like on the floor of
a single wide mobile home and then he
like pops his claws and just like to me
the Edgar Ramirez has that like guy you
could you wouldn't want to pick him up
hitchhiking and that's important whereas
be like Mama take this risk oh sure yeah
absolutely and I mean you know even
though even though you can assume that
Dean Winchester probably smells bad you
don't factor that in you know no it
doesn't come up when you're in your
lusting no you you just your brain still
makes you imagine this smells amazing uh
okay so we got more casting DC Beast Boy
Jaden Martel
I stood feet away from him at the Shazam
Premiere I'm into this Jade Martell pic
uh I like him he's the right age he
should be a boy it's Beast Boy uh I like
his skills as an actor so I'm into that
and then we got Alexander Ludwig for
Booster Gold man uh I don't know his
work but I recognize his face bad boys
for life I recognize him younger he was
in Race to Witch Mountain
sure I remember that's why I know that
that's so funny what a pull for my weird
brain oh he was also in Stephen amell's
heels okay yeah I know this guy
um yeah I I personally don't know his
work enough for that but if you like him
I'm into it okay cyborg we got Michael B
Jordan which that would be a direct rip
from a couple of the animated joints
that'd be fun man he had a Michael B
cyborg in one of those yeah the
athleticism the Cockiness but like the
leadership qualities I'm into that
that's one where it's like this seems
like a go-to choice but I would be like
yeah makes perfect sense there it is
um and probably because I've already
heard him do it but uh Green Arrow Jake
Gyllenhaal uh you know I would say Kyle
Raynor more than uh Hal Jordan for that
because uh Green Arrow works for Oliver
Queen and all those things but I I I I
feel like Green Arrow's got a bit of a
um
no I take it back he has a humor that
Jake Gyllenhaal does have and that
actually does work for me just for some
reason I can't picture it like I can't
it doesn't come to my mind's eye but
like his attributes work so I I'd have
to see it but I'm in oh yeah I would
have to see the if he could transform I
associate the green arrows just and I I
haven't seen the Stephen Amell take as
much but I associate the green arrow
with having that sort of like Arrow yeah
flindness and so that's what I would
need to kind of see him access I guess
not to pigeonhole I guess I would want I
hear Gyllenhaal and DC I think like give
him like a wild character yeah let him
go prisoners Jakey Jake's yeah
crazy or something like that yeah yeah
uh and then we got Green Lantern Jon
Stewart uh chuatel edgia four
it's fun uh I definitely think he's got
the chops I don't know if he'd want to
commit to a roll for like 10 years like
that he doesn't seem like a franchise
guy but I'd be interested I feel like
yeah I would like to see him somewhere
in here but yeah I feel like you would
also need a slightly younger actor at
this point impulse Lucas Hedges oh
that's an interesting poll uh he was
exceptional in honeyboy
um he's a really good actor that pops up
a lot yeah uh I definitely think he has
the darkness for impulse and he's got
the humor um if you've never seen
Manchester by the Sea dude is like
terrifyingly good I'm into that I like
that one all right Hells yeah and then
we got the last one help me with this
pronunciation Mr Mixie political
that's how I've always pronounced it I
obviously I've never heard it said but
mixer uh he's the guy that you have to
say his name to get him to go away is
that little impish demon guy and he's
like a Superman bad guy I want it Mr
Mixie Playboy could be a really fun
Superman him and bat might teaming up
yeah let's do it as ten taika YTD is The
Fan cast uh I'm into it uh you need
someone that's gonna be a little
nefarious uh that voice is definitely
nefarious a little impish well and that
could also bring I feel like there's
been sort of an odd
taika's role in the public sphere is
yeah altered over time you know
Hollywood taikas you know people have
their feelings about Hollywood taika and
so I feel like this could be a fun way
to let him play yeah and to kind of turn
that tide a little bit you know give him
somebody who we're not supposed to
directly like but like watching yeah
Raven Jenna Ortega oh that's fun uh
that's definitely like leaning into the
Wednesday of it all and I like that uh
Jenna Ortega is definitely uh like she's
such a rising star I'm actually
surprised she hasn't announced anyone
yet because like I feel like every
studio is like we need Jenna Ortega so I
love that yeah and get I mean dude get
get uh
I mean that would be that would be a
Titan's character right yeah like her
and sholo playing off each other and
whoever else a little Timmy chalamet is
Robin
I mean as much as he is like the one of
those go-to names everyone wants to cast
and everything if you want to sell it
totally see that you get those names no
you do and and yeah I can totally see so
much fun doing a pretty good uh
especially if they're going Damien uh
flash if they're recast Taryn Edgerton
everyone like I feel like Tara she's the
most cast man of all like Fan cast I
love that for him because he's great but
yeah I never thought of Flash no I never
did either it's funny he doesn't I feel
like you do need like kind of a tall
actor yeah kind of tall slightly less I
I he's bulky he's my Building height
like Taron Edgerton is a bit of a thick
bull I'm not I'm not a runner uh Taren
Edison is actually closer to Wolverine
for me uh but he's got the humor so and
he's an optimistic guy sure and then
Jason Clark for reverse flash oh I like
Jason Clark a lot uh I definitely don't
know if he he's an actor I don't know if
he'd want a franchise roll because it's
what Terminator did after Terminator
not uh you know he'd be a really
interesting Lex Luth her yeah I think so
I think I feel like that would match his
age bracket for this a bit more like I
could I could see him almost in an
alternate universe having been Zod or
something yeah that's fun I like that
yeah so uh but not bad this is these are
solid fans man I love a good Fan cast
but enjoyed that Mega breakdown and
these were lovely maybe at some point
I'll bust out my DC you know my Justice
League Fan cast if I can find it
efficiently enough
um let's move on to Raccoon shampoo very
random very thank you I really think the
flash uh creation uh Keaton's cowl uh
would feel really satisfying to touch it
looks like very smooth material I agree
it does have this like rubbery thing
that that doesn't work against it in a
weird way I definitely think that bad
suit inspired a lot of fetishes so I I
definitely think you're right and I
think Michelle Pfeiffer thinks the scene
a bunch of green and she's actually had
the pleasure of touching it's true so in
her cat suit did a lot of Awakening as
well oh
hello there uh you should Kenya happy
Saturday to you uh thank you for the
love and contribution thank you for
being here and for for always being here
I feel like you are one of our most
dedicated regs in here and I I
appreciate you very much what DC uh care
I almost said oh no there is Christmas
in here all right what cc characters
would you like to see in their own
Christmas special you can control
Christmas special
Doom Patrol Christmas let's do that if
there hasn't been one already because
it's Canon and it's ridiculous I want to
see Lobo fight Santa
that's happened and then kiss has to
swoop in yeah yeah so yeah I also um uh
it'd be really cool to see like green
and red characters like Green Lantern
and Flash like it'd be fun to see uh
like their visual manifestations of
powers like I don't I don't think that's
ever been done to scale like that fun
comickiness I'd love to see Green
Lantern and Flash to like us other
Christmas team up just because they're
green and sure like dumb stuff like that
like it's time some weird reason the
Justice League is like they're all away
YouTube it's the holidays and you guys
Gotta Be The Beacon of Peace like
Sinestro in reverse flash like team op
as villains like it's something that
linear but then you've got an optimistic
uh flash with Barry and then you've got
like you know Hal Jordan being all like
proud like I think it'd be great and
then you could do every possible holiday
just by pairing them off by colors into
it I love it uh yeah and I also I also
think uh oh oh what was I gonna damn it
oh that had a good one I wanna I wanna
very Constantine Christmas oh I like
that I want to see uh decorating the
house of mystery and then all they're
trying to do is sell celebrate Christmas
and a bunch of demonic keeps
getting every time you plant something
that's setting an incantation those they
have to decorate the house properly yeah
to like see like a certain summoning
thing yeah I also want to see uh Joker
steal the Batmobile uh and like I want
to see the live-action version of the
jingle like the the Batman song from our
clients adapted to live action oh my God
the Christmas special one is just but
it's like Pattinson's gloomy the Batman
at Christmas like and and Barry Robin
poor Robin yes what is gonna happen to
why how is he gonna lay that egg oh it's
got to happen oh my God I love this more
leave sound off in the comments with
your ideal uh uh DC Christmas special
and a quick uh actually just a one very
brief let's keep it quick because we do
have to uh get to the rest of the super
chats before we skip Daddle we're
getting close to the end of the stream
here but uh but how do you think Blue
Beetle will be incorporated moving
forward in the DCU and do you think it
is contingent on its success uh I do I
think that blue Beetle has the
interesting spot of being either the
like half included or not included I
think that if it does well uh there's a
shot in the Blue Beetle trailer with all
of the Blue Beetle um the old Blue
Beetle suits the very last shot uh Greg
actually pointed out to me that there's
like the three suits in the background
so this could be like in the future Blue
Beetle and then Booster Gold could be a
show set in the 80s with the other Blue
Beetle like there's elements of time you
could use
um because I also think it'd be really
interesting to have a commentary on
consumerism and Blue Beetle being a
proud man from the future if he was from
our present and he goes back to the 80s
there's things you could do that would
allow Blue Beetle to play but I do think
that the movie itself would need to do
well enough to bring sholo in because
there are elements that I think are
going to have to be reshot or have
already been shot that tied to the old
DC EU so I think it's a movie in between
worlds okay I'm gonna do a quick tandem
of little comments here because there's
a good chain of them in the chat uh
Taron Edgerton might be better as Green
Arrow actually I like that a lot that's
fun I like that quite a bit Evan Peters
Lexus Thor would be good uh that's just
always playing villains teetering on on
Eisenberg territory but I would love to
see what Evan Peters would do with that
I want to see him as a Mr uh the uh they
got the scars
um Victor zazz Evan Peters let Evan
Peters rest okay I would love that too
though I I would I I loved what
christmasina did but I would love to see
Evan Peters uh as as
um I uh hus d uh 21 says I'd rather see
Anthony Starr's reverse flash he gets
cast a lot and this is probably the
first one I have been like
I like that I like Miss Dracula oh yeah
he's got that Cheshire Grinch and him
versus mahershala yes oh do it all day
every day Timothy Charlamagne Homo
erectus says is the barbecue sauce of
Hollywood great makes it better yep and
uh Gilmer Eric Smith Joe curious Wally
AKA best version flash you know Joe
Curie is actually my backup Booster Gold
if Billy Madison doesn't want it but I
love Wally West getting some love and
Joe Kerry be a perfect balling dude I I
I think uh anytime we can Heap some love
go check out some of his Joe music as
well like uh his Tunes quit a bit uh
just checking up on the stream Labs we
get over there let's hop back to the
supers chills ww thank you for joining
us in Shilling for these various
properties and for the moment of silence
very much appreciated
David Wright uh thank you for joining in
the chat as well do you think we will
ever see live action Dark Knight Returns
adaptation enjoying your animated
reactions you should check it out and
hello from Scotland hello to Scotland
got a couple of Celtic boys in the room
yeah that's right although you're more
Irish generally yeah but yeah you know
we both got the Scottish in there it's
good
um yeah do you think we'll see a live uh
action Dark Knight not for a long time I
think that uh they did as close to it as
as comfy with Batman uh with Ben Affleck
so I think that if you let a Batman you
cast now age a bit it'd be a really
interesting take I also think that if
they do Multiverse and elseworlds and
stuff like that maybe it'll be a
different Batman altogether might be a
good way to have Jefferson Morgan get to
play uh but I I don't think that's
anytime soon because we've had something
similar and they really need to Branch
out I think the Batman and Batman Brave
and the Bold are already two different
takes and they need to get those
stronger first yeah and I mean for for
what that story necessitates I almost
feel like the inner it would be I almost
feel like you need a more isolated world
yeah to do something like that which
kind of is I counter to what they
already have I don't really see it as
part of what Pattinson's doing at the
moment and I don't really see it as
being what they want to do for brave in
the Bold unless they start that off with
Batman returning but then it's going to
be like conflicted in terms of what
adaptation is trying to be so yeah I
don't see that happening soon yeah A99
thank you so much for uh chiming in once
again glad Multiverse madness has fans
hope Marvel can win me back too oh damn
well hey I mean the guardian's gonna be
great yeah and and I mean you know
comment in the chat what would it take
for them to win you back is there
anything in particular or is it just you
know you're just waiting for that one
that gives you uh uh you know that that
you know ineffable just like nah I'm
back that's the one uh and TKO Dave they
do not only read if you pay we just get
as many as we can there's a lot but yeah
a lot of people joined in and we want to
make sure that their time is honored so
we do our best to jump between you guys
out here we do our best to to show some
love to all forms of the chat and uh and
we're reading we got the whole thing
right here home alone Ollie O'Donoghue
detective home alone is exactly the kind
of special I hope the DC what was that
movie Dustin checks in Dunstan what was
that kid's movie with like a chimp home
alone I think there was like a Dunston
was it what was it was like a night it
was super 90s let's see if I just made
up a fever dream done Jackson Jason
Alexander Faye Dunaway I had no idea
this even existing okay what's the plot
am I crazy or is this about like an ape
On The Run alone a four-star hotel is up
okay let's see
saw our hotel yo the 90s were crazy run
by Jason Alexander a young boy befriends
a larceness orangutan in a luxury hotel
writes itself yeah it writes itself oh
my god well hey let's get that one going
bring this tone back with Detective chip
I think it's about 890s Nostalgia is
part of the salad right now 96 man weird
times Bryce Burris shouts out and thank
you for contributing
and for holding it down in the main chat
as well odds they kill off Kang and make
Doom
uh The Avengers six villain uh up in the
air I feel like
I don't know I mean I almost feel like
they would recast sooner than it ain't
called the Doom Dynasty yeah and I feel
like unless he's our I could only see
him appearing there if he was already
slated to appear there I I also that
kind of pivot is what they're gonna do
Doom has done multiversal stuff but not
to the scale of Kang like right now they
need the Multiverse exploded they need
to bring it back in I think before Doom
so sure I don't think it works for the
story they're telling you yeah
absolutely uh Christian oh no no Jeff
Carroll here we go forgot one more Fan
cast that's good I'm glad you're being
comprehensive we would expect no less
Caitlyn Dever as Jean Gray oh I loved so
I and your next line is actually my Camp
Fan cast which is funny she is my kitty
Pride uh Caitlyn diva is very talented
and I think she's got so much heart that
she was able to keep up with like George
Clooney and Julia Roberts uh if if you
guys didn't see that rom-com it was
delightful
um what's it called I forget it's not oh
it's not her main movies it was cute uh
but by Caitlyn Dever is very very good
uh I would love to see her leading
something and I I think personally Kitty
pride is more how I see her because
Kitty pride has this um chip on her
shoulder because of like she literally
becomes a pirate in the in the post
talks box run and she has sacrificed
herself by like staying in a bullet in
the astonishing run she's always like
kind of a loner like she's got this
thing uh actually they were gonna make
this a movie um the last thing that got
canceled in the fox X-Men movies there
was this thing called x186 I think it
was and it was going to be an adaptation
of the Christmas issue of kitty Pride
Fighting like a demon with um her Dragon
uh lockjaw and her fighting like a demon
at Christmas they were gonna make a
Christmas X-Men movie and that was one
of the last things Fox had to cancel and
I've always thought like yeah Kitty
probably be a great lead because she
does like loner stuff a lot to me
Caitlyn Deever has more of that loner
quality than the team leader Gene gray
quality not that she couldn't play it
but I see Jean Gray as more of a Sophia
lilis than uh Caitlyn Deaver absolutely
people fan casters Kitty but watch dope
sick she can play tortured in a conflict
perfectly okay I'll check out some dope
I've heard good things uh let's see here
Christian unpronounceable I would love a
script written by Margaret Weiss and
Tracy Hickman
just for any DC thing yeah I don't know
what we were talking about before I
probably tied into what we were saying
at the time yeah just now when you go
back and see what we got from Christian
just to just to see what the connective
tissue if it's if it's related to your
previous comment but uh but uh I also
don't know those rights let's look these
writers up really quick and there's been
a lot of like writing switcheroos and
stuff like that or at least you know
writing announcements happening on the
Marvel side uh you know are you feeling
confident about these changes like you
know they just got uh one of the the guy
who was Heavy working on the script for
Avatar 2 to come in and work on uh what
was that is it King Dynasty Fantastic
Four yeah because I was like yeah
they're definitely gonna have Johnny
storms gonna say a lot of cousin bro now
yes give me a lot 80 uptick of cuz uh I
you know I I think Avatar 2
um its heart is better than its writing
uh I love the idea of the biggest
Blockbuster ever being about you know
respecting your planet you live on uh
but I don't necessarily think of the
writing as as like oh my God the writing
an avatar so like they don't really
Inspire more or less hope I really just
uh am in a position of wait and see with
what phase five ends up shaking out as
hell's yeah uh I guess Margaret Weiss
and Tracy Hickman oh they wrote books
together Dragons of Autumn night ooh
interesting so like fantasy books it
looks like better cover I mean yeah I
bet that could be really cool I mean you
know coming out of novels to screenplays
if that's kind of the direction we're
going is certainly you know they're
different beasts but especially I mean I
imagine to write these kinds of novels
not that I know the quality of them but
especially if you're suggesting them I
would assume that their writing is is
quality and yeah to write fantasy like
that I mean you've got to be able to
command a lot of lore and characters and
you know that's thick I would argue so
that could be very interesting um
especially I don't know if there's maybe
getting into the more uh magical side of
the DCU you know some of that justice
league dark kind of stuff
I'm just scrolling through here really
quick but yeah are you confident in some
of these writing updates that Marvel has
had uh because I've seen some people
online being like you know ah you know
these these Rick and Morty writers and
stuff they all suck but uh I don't know
like Michael Waldron also wrote Loki so
right now he's batting 500 for me
because like I didn't love the writing
in Multiverse but that was a studio
influence decision by a lot of turns and
I do think Loki was genius yeah I feel
like I feel like the writers of these
movies especially are kind of put in a
difficult position because so much is
I'm sure especially not up to them and
I'm sure that like what you've written
will be Rewritten either by you or
somebody or by another writer and so
like I think actually pulling in you
know I feel like the online sentiment
becomes you know like these Rick and
Morty writers is what I hear a lot and I
feel like in a lot of ways it's not a
bad call to pull those people because
they clearly have a grip on some level
of the humor that you want but also the
the broad science fiction and the pop
culture that you want volume they're
writing a lot and the volume and I think
that those aren't bad decisions but I do
think that yeah having maybe like
another writer who is you know used to
holding down like a for a three-hour
plus epic or whatever like can only
you don't want a million writers on a
script necessarily but I think the fact
that they are putting this energy and
effort into the scripts and into you
know making these kinds of decisions
that's heartening to me because uh
because yeah I feel like oftentimes
especially with Marvel movies or
whatever it might be the script is
crucial and the script is often
something that could be you get to the
final product and I always feel bad
talking about the writer when talking
about the right thing because that's
just like uh so much of this is probably
not entirely in your control
um but hey Johnny your ranking of the
boys Seasons uh Now That season four is
done filming
two one three okay and not the three was
bad I just didn't uh
it felt like every single week I was
definitely in and I was focused and I
was I was joyous but it wasn't the same
like I'm counting down the six days
between the episodes like I was with two
and one wasn't bad by any means but it
had a lot to just build so I just think
that like it found a sweet momentum in
two and uh they're all three seasons all
of those are higher than damn near any
other show though like even three which
is my lowest is still an a Which is
higher than 90 of TV absolutely I think
you know I I might revise this upon a
re-watch of the show it's I've really
enjoyed the show across the board the
first season really like
like I just vividly remember the sort of
shotgun blast of like wow this is I am
not used to this and this is wild and uh
and yeah I I might put this first season
at the top for me just because of that
sheer
and and again not to say that the
continuation of the show have been
contrived or bad or anything but there
is that also that that kind of quality
of like man anything can happen and
nobody needs to be kept around
necessarily there's no there's no
finagling to be like okay how is
homelander not just destroyed everything
but maintaining his max villainy and I
think they do a good job with that but
yeah like just the the power and
freshness of the first season puts it
pretty strong and then I feel like for
me two and three kind of grapple yeah
because they're there are things about
both of them that are just so wild and
and you know and Vivid and memorable
um I don't know I feel like the season
two if I'm remembering correctly there
were aspects where
I can't remember it was two or three
where it felt like maybe some of the
boys weren't quite as crucial and then I
thought kind of season three maybe
brought it back to that if I'm
remembering correctly but uh but yeah I
I I might go I don't know if it's one
two three or one three two yeah I feel
like they were all very exceptional yeah
so good and actually I forget who asked
in the main chat but um someone wanted
to know then um do you think that uh
what what are your hopes in
anticipations do you think that intuous
patients do you think that uh Generation
V will be good or do you think it'll
amount to more of like a you know uh the
the Mandalorian 2.5 That Boba Fett
became I don't think that Rogan or
Kripke would risk that like I I feel
like Disney
um with their
they make less toys of the boys uh so I
feel like they have a bit of a focus
um so I don't think there would be a um
need to grow it out uh obviously money
is good but like they don't need to grow
it they could just keep making the boys
whereas if they want to grow the world
there's a reason behind it so I trust in
the reasoning behind uh the the new
shows absolutely I hope it's good yeah I
hope I I hope that they can I think
there's a lot you can do and I would
love to see them build out the universe
you know effectively that way I hope it
I mean you know I feel like there are
certain uh
you know like The Walking Dead is
certainly kind of a
a touchstone for things like this and I
hope that they can just yeah uh just
keep growing out awesomeness yeah for
sure
um okay let's see Heather gear thank you
for the sticker love it uh waving right
back at you thank you for just being so
lovely here in these streams over on
patreon all that good stuff your support
and your love is is always a A nice
bright spot each week uh Dan v900
welcome back uh also the Super Chat
super chats have been closed for now as
we're we're nearing the end here but uh
Captain Marvel was a very Bland film
Brie Larson was directed poorly when you
compare her other work as an
oscar-winning actress the Marvel zfx
looks rough at times the trailer wasn't
impressive I'm sorry that that you're
not digging on the new trailer I do
think that that yeah it should be
acknowledged that you know a lot of
people might only know Brie Larson
through Captain Marvel but she has been
terrific in a lot of others got Pilgrim
room yeah like she's incredible yeah was
she in Short Term 12 too yes yeah she's
great in that like yeah I think she gets
a bad rap and uh I hope that you know
the I'll always give the benefit of the
doubt to VFX until we're actually at the
movies same because they're working on
it now so I don't really judge from
trailers personally and yeah the trailer
wasn't exactly what I had necessarily
expected and it didn't necessarily make
me like oh my God like
like you know I can I can understand if
you maybe weren't that enthralled by it
but I I liked it quite a bit um but
thank you for your thoughts on the
matter raccoon shampoo
all the love to you could Western Comics
work with close to one-to-one
adaptations like anime or novels it's
unusual how few comic added patients
follow the one-to-one style despite it
being common in other media and why
might this be uh I feel like it's not
the comics aren't made to be adapted
they're made to be digested with your
imagination in a different way like
anime and novels are as well uh but I I
don't know anime as well as Comics so I
can't say how those adaptations differ
because I don't have the exposure to
anime but I think that comic books are
okay for example if you look at a comic
panel and you go to the next panel your
imagination is the director between the
panels you're controlling the pace
you're controlling the edit you're
controlling the speed you're controlling
how it feels and and sounds so when you
make a movie
that's a hundred people describing that
that's the lighting that's the sound
that's the director that's the actors
that's literally the cinematographer
everything is different so I don't think
it's possible to do a one-to-one
adaptation and I think when you try it's
a failure because your brain's going
like I wanted this thing exactly like
this and it's too close it's kind of
like The Uncanny Valley so I think it's
better to do things like Civil War and
better do things like you know Winter
Soldier which is like you get the core
of the storyline and you make it work
for the movie Universe you're adapting
absolutely I would agree Dom thank you
for your contribution uh Charlie Heaton
for Wolverine if he could bulk up he is
uh Jonathan the brother on Stranger
Things I believe uh he was just
Cannonball
um Charlie Heaton um I'm like the one
guy that really like New Mutants
um but Charlie uh is definitely okay
this is gonna sound mean but it isn't he
does have that energy of like I don't
know if that guy smelled good but uh I
just I I just there's no other way to
say it you said it yeah I was thinking
it but I think that he's more of a oh
how do I put this he's more of a ghost
writer type in that I feel like his
darkness and his edginess comes from a
place of
um despair versus Vengeance so like
Ghost Rider has a certain like I'm Gonna
Keep soldiering on but I'm a Broken Man
Wolverine's broken but he's angry about
it so that's a different energy to me so
I got nothing against Charlie heat and I
just don't get his Vibe as mirroring
that as well okay also there's a ton of
Laz Alonso love in the chat and that
makes me really happy because I got a
lot of love for Laz Alonso as an actor
also uh you know Fast and Furious Alum
so if you get if you get fast and
furious and uh the boys I got a lot of
love for that oh hell uh also Laz and I
have been scheming and cooking up some
stuff lies is a good dude so excited
excited to hear more about that also
thank you Anthony Abrego uh for the John
and koi Duo love we we love doing we
love I love collabing with you yeah same
man it's always fun much good time much
appreciate you and we I saw some
comments earlier that we weren't keeping
it on track we are like we've gotten
through a ton of questions we went
through the headlines I feel like this
could have gone much away I'm sure it
could have been better and more
organized but I'm sure it could have
also been worse also those comments were
only in the beginning so that feels good
that it hasn't continued so we have done
our job Kurt bus uh Dan v900 says and
thank you for for jumping in again into
the uh the super chats uh Kurt busiak
criticized the Marvel's title when it
was announced since it's nothing like
his series he did with Alex Ross I wish
it had a different title not a big fan
of using the title in that way
huge fan a Kurt but uh the Marvels is a
brand uh if you've got Captain Marvel
and Miss Marvel and another character
who has gone by Captain Marvel who goes
by Spectrum seemingly it works
narratively so I would have loved loved
to have seen the Marvels adapted because
the Marvels is one of my favorite
um
like you're a civilian looking up at
these gods in Marvel usually that's a DC
thing and it's illustrated by Alex Ross
who's a painter so it's these stunning
vistas of like imagine if Galactus was
just in the sky filling the sky the book
feels huge and it's uh from the
perspective of uh Your akuza Daily Bugle
writer uh he's a journalist so you're
literally an eye line with someone
writing about superheroes through the
Marvel history it's a genius title for
the comic book but in the movie world
you need that brand recognition so the
Marvels I think is a great title even
though it's not an adaptation and this
is actually a great example of what we
were just talking about how it's a
different medium so you're gonna have
different expectations and hey worst
case scenario his book sells good like
Curt music like that's a good thing to
people like oh this isn't what I thought
it was but this is great absolutely
there you go
nice thoughts there koi I appreciate
that
uh Justin Seymour thank you for
contributing here uh in the super chats
Renfield is totally awesome uh I had
pretty low expectations but I was blown
away by how much bloody fun it was it is
one of the bloodiest movies I've ever
seen
um it's also a fun fact my buddy
acquaintance Mr Chris Brewster uh who
was my stunt double on Star Trek who
became a friend uh he was the hallway
fight in Daredevil and he was the stunt
coordinator which means he oversaw the
stunts and second unit director for
Enfield so if you like the stunt work
which is incredible in that movie it's
because of the man who brought you
Winter Soldier and Daredevil really
quick oh hey yeah there's a reason the
Winter Soldier fights the best because
it's the guy that was in the Daredevil
suit like Chris is an actual ninja his
uh social media is ninja brewski and he
is one of the best stunt people I have
ever known he's incredible oh sweet dude
I'm
all the all the things like I've been
hearing since Renfield came out are
getting me very very excited also really
quick going back to the last question uh
Marvels I remember at one point I was
picking your brain because I was like oh
wait there's a specific comic I cannot
identify and it's got this and this and
this and this art style was that the
Marvels it's a uh or was that a Marvel's
it's got a very like painted looking
style and yeah we talked about it like
there's like a human they've got the
human torchion like a case okay it's
exactly that book we talked about two
years ago because it's short but it
expands a lot of time and it's got
impact it's great yeah oh you know just
a just a quick one-off uh sentiment
thrill killer adapt that uh is that
the one where the Joker's a lady
I don't know that run hold on uh anyway
Michael I'll pull it up because I might
be quoting the wrong comic name but
Michael Bean
we love you stay alive and movies in
life yeah and uh
keep uh you know keep holding it down
with the old Jimmy camera uh and he and
his wife produce movies now uh Michelle
Blanc uh if you were in charge of
casting decisions and Pedro Pascal was
interested in joining the MCU what hero
or villain would you koi genre cast him
as
Norman Osborne uh I want to see him use
his innate charm to convince the
American public that he's a good guy
when every bit of fact shows that he's a
bad guy and you need someone I always
say Tom Hanks should be a great Norman
Osborne which people don't like see but
it's because he's America's dad like you
need someone that is so like Norman
Osborne won the presidency in the comic
books Norman Osborne ran the dark
Avengers Norman Osborne was also the
head of one of the biggest corporations
in the world while obviously being the
Green Goblet it's it's it needs to be
someone that is so likable that you
don't like you can't see what's right in
front of your face and Pedro Pascal is
charm incarnate so uh I'd love to see
him play a villain where it's not
trapped in a rough script but uh one
that he got to use that Pedro's charm
read that koi read that I have no oh I
love Howard shaken I have not read this
read that it's a good ass night is that
from the early 2000s because that go t
is suspect probably I mean I remember
Greg and I checking it out from the
library like probably in the in the
2000s that would have been around the
time uh so yeah just a good old uh but
yeah I I agree with the with the Pedro
Pascal yeah uh because yeah you need to
I feel like too you can't have him be
too Maxwell gold right exactly like I
and I think he wants to play a villain
so let him but go over there let him
yeah and let him actually be a villain a
villain gala ghost what's up Andres it's
good to see you in in here uh once again
thank you as well jumping in and give us
uh giving us some love oh yeah that's
right congratulations I'm jealous man I
miss Boston hey hey koi oi koi much love
for the both of you are you looking
forward to PS5 Spider-Man 2 this fall
Tony Todd his Venom his fire cheers
fellas it got like a little New York at
the end there but I support it
uh are you looking forward to this I am
I mean like I haven't uh I haven't A PS5
uh and I need to catch up with these the
the you know the two prolific Spider-Man
games but what you had me at was Tony
Todd yes and uh and you know I've been
I've been snatching up some of the the
games that I can catch up with on my PS3
uh but at some point I'm gonna have to
move into the future and I would love to
be able to do that uh you know
coinciding with Spider-Man too because
yeah Tony Todd is a is amazing in any
form but especially he's got that voice
man and I cannot wait I bought a PS4 for
Spider-Man 2. I'm hoping they're kind
and let me have a PS4 version of this I
doubt it because they want to sell PS5
but I really hope I don't want to buy
into the system uh that said I mean if
they do a PS4 I might have a little yeah
you might have a little fruit maybe
upgrade I don't have to wait you know
for them to choose me to get a PS5 I
that's before but uh my buddy Yuri is
Spider-Man so I um
but he hasn't told me a thing because
he's a good man but his excitement is so
clear when I ask about it and he tells
me nothing that I'm really confident
like I love that Yuri's so excited that
even though he won't say any specifics
like his Glee and like it's it's
palpable so I'm excited just because
like one I love my dude but also like he
knows how good that first game was I
don't think he'd be this like oh you're
not ready if it wasn't exceptional so
I'm very excited Hells yeah Aisha Kenya
Tom Hardy as Wolverine he has the acting
chops the rugged look he's five eight
and he can lead a franchise thoughts I
feel like he could smell it up but uh
but you know what do you think koi uh
you know that's actually a really good
point Tom Hardy can smell it up Tom
Hardy is like the definition of like he
can be both the Charming guy in uh This
Means War as well as like oh man Bronson
that guy isn't bathed ever
um and I think that's his power like Tom
Hardy is one of the best chameleon
actors working and a lot of people don't
like his like muttering style but it
definitely suits Wolverine my only issue
is the brand recognition with Venom I do
think that like it'd be hard for Green
Lantern only got played by round
Reynolds once uh there are certain
actors that have become synonymous and I
do feel like there's going to be an
association there uh that said
um it also might be tricky that you know
Tom Hardy is
45 turning 46 he will start to look
older soon and Wolverine is not aging so
that's that's a little tricky like I
think you need to cast I'd actually cast
um in my I had to cast early 20s age
them up to look 30 that way as they age
they just look like they've aged like I
would find someone younger and age them
up digitally or with makeup and then let
them enter the Wolverine age myself
absolutely yeah I feel like I feel like
yeah Tom Hardy is
is a guy who could who could do it and I
would be excited to see do it but I feel
like it's not exactly like yeah he would
need to be maybe a little a little
younger and a little less I feel like
casting somebody too high profile almost
works against whoever yeah I agree
um because yeah I don't know like Hugh
Jackman partly Rose through Wolverine
yeah yeah
so I feel like you still need some of
that unknown quality even though he is
such a huge star now
um but yeah gala ghost uh back again
with a follow-up uh love the DC animated
reactions what's your favorite DC
animated film so fast cheers oh boy uh
every time we talk about like a top five
it always if we just get stressed yeah
I'm like okay what are the what are the
go-to's Red Hood Flashpoint Red Hood
Flashpoint uh turtles is so rad uh jail
dark yeah those are I think those are my
solid four and then the fifth one is the
newest one the newest one and also I'll
say uh the Gotham uh
the oh What's the title of that you know
where they have to assault an argument
assault on Arkham was exceptional too it
was wicked uh I would yeah those are
definitely my tops I would say the one
we just watched which we're teasing
heavily is in the top five it might have
been dropped out Arkham but that's it's
really hard to judge because of how good
Arkham was so uh yeah those are insane
yeah such a joy and uh yeah very excited
should be up tomorrow so they'll know
tomorrow look out for that man some good
punch lines in there uh Bryce Burris the
last Kingdom on Netflix is a must watch
thank you for the recommendation uh I
I've seen the the you know the
advertisements and I've seen it like pop
up on on the Netflix but I haven't seen
the show yet and uh it looks pretty
rollicking uh pretty pretty uh hardcore
period epic over here one of my favorite
shows ever was called Kingdom on Netflix
it used to be on um like DirecTV and
then I went to Netflix now with nowhere
I actually bought it because I I was so
worried about it never being seen again
that I own the DVDs uh but anytime I see
the naming Kingdom on Netflix I'm like I
miss I miss my baby Frank Grillo
Jonathan Tucker MMA show oh John Tucker
dude Jonathan Tucker is like great actor
I want him in a DC Marvel thing more
than anyone because he should be a
household name sure sure new new
Quicksilver let's do this yeah
or uh I don't know come up with your
best John Tucker actually yeah while you
read the next one I'm gonna think of
that all right raccoon shampoo when I
think of kingdom and Netflix I think of
the Korean zombie period piece which is
also great and we got reactions up for
that so go check them out uh elevator
pitch raccoon shampoo elevator pitch
true crime mockumentary series about
Silver age DC Villains that's fun I
would love that and also I want to shout
out in this moment uh uh friends of the
channel uh Giant Panda King Russell
Beatty I think he goes by you know he's
he just changed his name he's like
baboon God now or something but uh but
he did a terrific he and his crew did a
terrific
um take on the Batman characters called
Gotham uh uh oh God what are the years
39 to 1945 or something like that but
yeah it's like you know Art Deco takes
on you know it's like 1930s style like
film Noir takes on all these characters
and it's this beautiful book that's
presented like a case File with you know
photographs of you know the different
characters write-ups on them like little
you know uh police reports and things
like that like there's there's like a
whole you know sort of take on the lore
across this book
um that is you know it's it's a book but
it is presented almost like a piece of
True Crime Amalgamated in a way and it's
a really wonderful take so go check them
out uh at Giant Panda King and uh and
yeah just bask in the in the beauty of
that um because uh that kind of matches
what you're pitching here but I would
love to see something like that I think
that would be really fun I mean I I
always like that sort of um I don't know
you say Silver age so I flash back to
something that would be like a period
piece or something like that but I would
love some kind of True Crime documentary
in that vein uh for sure I got three
okay go uh Andrew Garfield Spider-Man
Hobgoblin because you cannot do Norman
Osborne I don't think now that you've
got Willem Dafoe and all that
interaction and no way home so you have
Ned leads be introduced as someone
that's uh working at The Daily Bugle
alongside Andrew Garfield so it's the
right age and you allow that Mania of
Jonathan Tucker to be the Hobgoblin to
allow him to have a goblin before he's
done if not hobgoblin he'd be a great
Eddie Brock I think like the the look of
of Jonathan Tucker allows for him to
play that 90s Todd McFarland he's not
blonde but he's got that like jock build
and I think that like the intensity of
his like manic energy opposite Andrew
Garfield would be really interesting and
again you can't do the Tom Hardy one
unless you fold it in which they could
but I think having his own Venom and
then finally I think he'd be a great
jigsaw for The mcu's Punisher in a
really unique way that I think like if
they don't use uh Ben Barnes jigsaw it'd
be really fun to see him play like a
military guy that came up and like you
know had to deal with all that stuff
bring back John Travolta yeah he's ready
uh but yeah this is uh Gotham 90 19 to
1939 and there's also I believe a
metropolis version that they've got as
well but yeah it's a it's really
beautiful and if they still I think they
just did a new addition so uh check them
out because it's really beautifully
realized um but yeah so hopefully maybe
kind of similar to your true crime pitch
here
um but yeah Louis Berry Josh Brolin as
Batman fion Whitehead as soups and
Timothy shalvez Willem Dafoe is the
Joker Brian Cranston as Lex Luthor oh
okay I love all that fantastic I think
Josh Brolin was like number two to be
Batman twice now uh I don't know if
Brolin is I don't know if he wants three
movies man I don't know if he wants like
to get in that kind of shape and stay
there uh that's just such a commercial
Batman yeah like that's a real
commitment um but I do love the idea of
him as a Batman like I think he's solid
I also don't know what age they're gonna
go with Batman because I don't think
they're gonna want him more than 10
years older than Superman so I think
he's going to be a young father Damian
Wayne's gonna be like nine
um so like you can have the dude be like
in his 30s very easily and I everyone's
going like 40s 50s but you could have a
30 year old Batman still with a young
child
um so I think Nicholas Holt uh would be
a pretty solid Batman
um because I think that he could be the
paternal thing I think that he's almost
been Batman before and I really see that
that he's so charming and interesting
and dark so I that's more of the
direction I'm going in I don't know if
fion Whitehead uh but the rest are a fan
cast I've had like I totally agree with
one proposed Joker I think Brian
Cranston is Lex Luthor uh so I agree
with the rest of yours I am the one who
knocks with Kryptonite
uh yeah yes
only solid choices in here uh gala ghost
back again dream Christmas special
Damien Wayne's home alone oh my God just
love it at Wayne Manor Anthony traps
yeah just making traps no one even
breaks in he's just doing it's just him
doing it to do it or you go the whole
Pantheon of Rogues that are like not
gonna ever get their solo movies and
they're all breaking into Wayne Manor
like they find out who Bruce Wayne is
and it's Damian's job to keep them out
to not prove that he is Batman like he's
got to keep them from discovering the
identity for certain and it's all the C
and D list villains sure oh my God I
would oh
guys call me I'll write your movies
there needs to be a yeah more Christmas
one thing we need more of in comic
movies and and properties a Shane black
Damien Wayne Christmas movie
Hollywood get on it all right make it
happen that is perf and that would be a
great way for Shane black to kick the
door in and join them you know who he's
DCU you know who joins the third act
making it a buddy cop thing Nightwing
yes you have to buddy cop have to
Nightwing Damien Wayne reluctant buddy
cop Nightwing and Damian Wayne is one of
my favorite relations it's right there
like I I Adore and uh and there's some
good stuff with that and the things that
we're about to watch uh tomorrow so well
this is just commercial for tomorrow's
video yeah yeah so I expect you all to
be there bright and early uh but yes uh
all the Chris more Christmas
more Halloween for me but but also just
I want more romance in these things I
want like a romantic comic book movie Mr
Freeze man dude I'm telling you make a
Ryan Gosling Mr Freeze movie that's
basically just like the notebook put
with crime yes it's right there being a
sweeping Nicholas Sparks epic with crime
I love that like we get these little
tastes and I'm like come on you cowards
love same with star as much as people
dog that's episode six Mandalorian this
season I was like but they had some
romance yeah it is a sterilized romance
from franchises like it's a really weird
phenomenon that there isn't as much like
passion or love or like connection
between human beings I think it's in
part because we're not like experiencing
it to scale in life I think the writers
don't realize they're missing it because
in life we're so digital we're so
removed we like we don't connect as a
species anymore and I think our art is
reflecting that it's just really
alarming to see it's because romance is
for girls boys super girls don't like
movies for girls
go watch Sir Nicholas Sparks for real
yeah
um no that's that would be my bat before
we move on that would be my Batman and
Catwoman movie would just be like like
Before Sunrise but with uh yeah and a
Catwoman on the rooftop game dude I'd
love that put some crime in there but
then just intersperse it with them just
walking and talking and having to love
that a Richard link later before
Trilogy with batcat would be so good
that's gonna be my Opus oh my God
someday uh dough eyes oh no no Dom uh
can we petition for a young justice
watch through with you two I mean maybe
when we're done with all the movies
maybe 2027 yeah yeah we'll see what
happens but I mean anything anything DC
anything animated anything you want to
do yeah let us know in the comments of
these videos because that's the best way
to like see them contained so like right
in the videos the comment like what you
want to see because there's also like
that's substantial uh there's also like
some marveled animated stuff I haven't
seen so yeah let us know yeah we gotta
we got a definitely like a treasure
Trove of Marvel stuff too uh but yeah I
love the idea and we'll definitely take
it under consideration doe eyes cheers
and happy Saturday back at you
appreciate the love cheers and happy
Saturday Lads cheers to you doe eyes and
uh Hey keep uh keep keep baking over
there
uh Robbo 96. hey guys do you think
they've missed an opportunity not
putting Short Round in the new indie
movie and also what are your
expectations for it
I'm still like vaguely Holding Out for a
surprise saying you know like I almost
feel like if they could keep that a
secret and you know there's not the
amount of ravenousness to uncover you
know plot details on a movie like that
I'm sure there are leaks and things but
uh I think that would be the most
gratifying surprise and uh and so lovely
if they could do that and that would be
like just those pictures of him and
Harrison Ford like reuniting and hugging
it out yeah I feel I'm feeling them
maybe cause some reshoots like if you
had the time yeah you had the time yeah
and like and and especially if this is
going to send off the character and
everything I feel like it would be a
lovely thing for them to do also and I
mean they could DH them if they have to
and he doesn't even look that much older
it would be very plausible that he's at
least something of an adult now yeah
depending on the years because Temple of
Doom is the earliest set movie anyway so
the year was 2018. the network Nerdist
the show I forget I was on as a guest
and one of the people uh asked what you
would do for Indy five before Fort was
ever made because Chris Pratt was in the
news again as maybe being Indy five it
was like oh no five or six years ago and
I said on record the only way I'd want
anyone to take the hat from him would be
short round getting it because he's the
right age and it's also you make it more
techy by using all the like stuff
literally pitched this as the spin-off
and like I would love if at least he's
physically there now that he got an
Oscar dude like let the guy play Hells
yeah and I mean that would be one of the
few scenarios we're like doing Legacy
characters spin-off but in the same vein
would just kind of it just seems kind of
natural yeah instead of like a reach so
yeah man I've always wondered where
Short Round has been right enough time
yeah Justice for Short Round And I love
your idea and I hope it happens I hope
it comes to pass uh and if they don't
put them in I do think it I'm we'll see
how the movie is I trust James Manuel oh
yeah but yeah I would feel maybe just a
smidge bummed if it didn't happen uh
just bread VR uh we we've talked about
this a couple times now but we will
address it once again uh before we get
out of here today uh yeah what happened
to reaction to Superman Loves
um Greg put it the most eloquently uh on
our stream last week but basically
um yeah there's a lot of stuff that that
we have here to cover and you know the
schedule I mean from the outside you
know it's like yeah there are lots of
things that we would love to be able to
just cover and put up and not have to
really be concerned with you know uh the
volume of videos and the algorithm and
the you know Way YouTube works when you
post a certain amount of videos in a day
there are a lot of considerations and
Superman and Lois while we love that
show and had a great time reacting to it
um you know
it didn't it just hasn't had the amount
of support
um to really kind of justify keeping
that slot uh when there are so many
other things to prioritize and also when
so many hours and so much Manpower goes
into these videos because again it
appears you know certainly from the
outside uh very kind of effortless I'm
sure
um but you know many hours you know it's
like you've got the hour and change hour
and a half it takes to shoot that and
then multiple hours go into the editing
of the highlights and the reviewing of
the highlights and then the thumbnails
and the posting all that stuff and so we
really wanted to continue with it and it
just hasn't really proven viable at the
moment so uh so a bummer
um never say never but I don't really
anticipate the react series continuing
in this form anyway
um so yeah big love for the show and
glad people are loving it but as a react
series
um yeah it just hasn't been
um quite what we need it to be
um to you know put that amount of
investment a head of other things so
yeah but I appreciate the love and and
you know I hope that people at least you
know enjoyed those first two seasons
with us because I can't wait to catch up
with season three it really like watch
it some added to your son it's on the 30
or 40. I forget what number but yeah
it's on there yeah it's it's I have
season two on Blu-ray I just haven't
watched season one or three yet I would
love to hear your thoughts because uh
especially you know with all the debate
about you know the different takes I
hear he's great and I hear the show is
Superman so I'd love to yeah time yeah I
mean even in my just sort of novice uh
uh relation to all these characters and
stories and what the what the truth of
them is supposed to be or the
quintessence of them is you know I felt
like they've done A really lovely and uh
and uh faithful job of you know adapting
Superman in a way that doesn't feel like
they feel hampered by yeah the character
needs to be and I think that's a good
thing you know
um so yeah dude how you how are you
feeling I mean we crushed the damn thing
we got many many super chats many many
stream Labs absolutely uh and live
chat's still moving uh I wanna have any
questions in here before we Boogie out
of here yeah let's see um
yeah I'm really sorry Tommy from Dunkirk
I do know that guy he would be a solid
Superman I see that I like that okay
okay sure yeah yeah and that's that's
another one of those choices where I'm
like okay I wasn't necessarily called it
but uh but yeah I could see it
definitely and it's one of those like
unlikely uh choices um and hey I don't
know maybe maybe you should react to
Superman Lois on your channel I got all
that time I gotta watch three seasons of
a show I got all that time if everyone
who comments about Superman and Lois
brings five friends and they all watch
that Lois and then they share the videos
with their five friends and all of a
sudden exponentials start popping off
you're like wow the show is exploding
season four yeah
um do you know Greg Wiseman I don't I
don't either I don't but hey shout him
out and let him know that we love him
anyway
um yeah a lot of Short Round love in the
chat
um Young Justice love in the chat
certainly we'll keep it under
consideration for sure a Warhammer
people excited for Henry cavill's
Warhammer I think Mario just definitely
helped it out I think there's gonna be a
surge of everything nerd and gamey
um
adaptation love soon I think the
Nintendo universe is going to be insane
but I also think there's gonna be a lot
of people being like make video game
movies yeah yeah well now now I know
that warhammer's not a video game but
like games are gonna because Dungeons
and Dragons didn't do as well as I think
they thought weekend one but it
continued to do okay and then I mean
Sonic did great and Mario did huge and
Last of Us yeah Last of Us yeah geez and
and and the hit Resident Evil many
adaptations everyone loves unanimously
across the board all of them
yeah uh and yes Jen Jacinda if the
notebook with crime doesn't sell you I
don't know what will that's exactly
that's the pitch we'll give you a
percentage of the back end I honestly
other than Deadpool can't think of a uh
like a romance in recent comic movies
that was like it felt like a part of the
story dude Cersei and
it's not Superman in the eternals first
I love that movie uh that is the the
part that like I actually liked Angelina
Jolie's relationship uh oh yeah way more
Gilgamesh yeah but like I just feel like
as a fixture of the film it's really
rare to have relationships in there yeah
I I I I get I can I can understand what
might be standing in the way in terms of
audience response but I feel like they
should at least in in certain places I
don't know I like the bat and the cat
and the Batman the cat maybe Peggy and
cap
yeah I don't know to a degree even
though that's not like spent a ton of
time on Giancarlo Esposito as Roderick
Kingsley hobgoblin he's a lot of
people's uh Magneto but I I think it'd
be a lot more interesting to have him as
Xavier yeah I want to see him not be the
bad guy yeah and Xavier's got his
Darkness but he's not the bad guy yeah
exactly Bohemian Rhapsody 2 has been
confirmed Is that real that cannot be I
do not what Aisha Kenya seems to think
you will not enjoy The Killing Joke
heard it's not great uh wow I guess this
must be real Bohemian Rhapsody too that
is odd to me that what are they going to
do the real version now what yeah are
they gonna actually tell the story of
the man into the revised version yeah
they just like actually tell who he is
oh God Freddie Mercury we're sorry what
are they doing and uh don't worry
they'll drop uh Transformers trailer
when you least expect it probably on a
Monday morning 6 a.m or something like
that who knows
um yeah oh guys thank you so much for uh
for joining us and for for making us
feel loved today I hope you've had a
good time I hope we've got to uh you
know at least a good amount of your
thoughts here in the chat as well as uh
thank you for all the super chat
contributions and just for helping you
know guide this conversation and and
yeah for making this such a joy for for
us as as much as we hope it is for you
uh some Alex Ross love yeah as well
um and yeah dude I I appreciate the love
for the three of us Aditya tripathi says
just love the trio John Greg and Coy I'm
glad I got koi from this channel been
following since much I've been following
him since much love from India and uh
Keanu Reeves or Norman Reedus is Ghost
Writer I think Normandy would just be an
excellent Ghost Rider uh I think Keanu
Reeves be an excellent Silver Surfer are
you in Into Darkness I am
I'm the nibirens that's what uh Chris
was my stunt double on so I'm I'm those
six actors cast as like 600 aliens so
I'm uh Mo capped and cloned so I'm like
dozens of aliens in that movie and I I
got scanned for video game I worked on
it for like five weeks uh we did a ton
of stuff on practical planets like JJ
actually built us a red planet like that
red planet and ninja Darkness was a
practical set and it was like a half a
football field long it was stunning to
like work on uh it was like eight hours
of makeup to get in and four hours get
out so our days were like 20 hours it
was one of the craziest jobs I've ever
had sounds like it was it was bananas
and they had us in um black contacts
that were um like almost as thick as uh
ping pong balls cut in half so I had to
have like a device to get the thing in
my eye because we were shot in IMAX
contacts because if so the IMAX camera
picks up so much light so if the light
got in and you could see through the
context the contact had to be made for
IMAX cameras so I was in seven layers of
latex and then I had these contacts in I
had fake teeth I had things covering my
ears so I was like blind and and
couldn't hear well and couldn't touch it
was the most disorienting they actually
had a marine
um psychologist on set because we
basically all went through like
claustrophobia training because we
couldn't feel or see or hear so we like
people were going into like panic and
stuff and we had to like coach through
that it was a really intense set but I'm
so honored to have been part of it dude
hell's yeah that's what yeah that's
where I met Chris that's lovely okay
last last thing before we skedaddle real
quick just a quick Domer okay Jamie
Campbell Bower would you cast him as
anybody vekna vechna one Jamie Campbell
Bower uh I would say he'd be a great
arcade in the MCU a villain for the
X-Men but also like a really interesting
commentary on game culture right now uh
I would say he'd be an interesting Harry
Osborne uh I would say he would be very
good as someone with like a manic energy
in the X-Men but he has like an Angelic
quality to him I'd almost say it'd be a
really good Archangel like if they
started with uh Warren as a good guy
because I could see him be good but then
like going dark and doing like the blue
Archangel storyline cool all right
and uh absolutely curly fries are better
than normal fries both are very
important though put them and get get
them combo man like most places are
sophisticated enough that you're gonna
just get them mixed in the Box you know
get your get your Buster Both Worlds um
but yeah guys thank you so much for
joining us thank you for uh there's a
hand heart thank you for all the love
and uh and yeah for for making this live
stream I hope a success maybe in the
future we'll be able to team up again
yeah that was fun man yeah no absolutely
uh it's always scarecrow great call sure
no absolutely that's just VEC nugen but
I'm into it sure
but I wouldn't be mad about it um yeah
guys thank you so much for joining us
leave a like that always helps out and
uh yeah we'll catch you on the next one
uh much love and have a great rest of
y'all see y'all soon and uh yeah be well
party on DC animated tomorrow
ending